Ich fühle mich schockiert, angstig, enttäuscht, ängstlich, ich fühle mich schockiert,
und eigentlich habe ich mich nicht bedenken.
wenn
der
nicht
Kassel
Ja, ich bin übrigens da.
Ich setze einfach nur da und drücke sinnlos E-Modes, als geht.
Eigentlich brauchen wir den anderen Papagei auch noch, als GIF oder als die Leute zu trickern,
als GIF, als GIF brauchen wir das.
Kann man nicht irgendwie suchen, die hatten doch irgendwie die Möglichkeit, dass man die
suchen kann, nach animiert oder nicht.
Ah nee, man konnte bloß transparent suchen.
Aber man kann Party Parrot GIF suchen.
Der ist vielleicht ein bisschen pixelig, um in Full HD anzuzeigen, oder?
Hat der einen transparenten Hintergrund?
Probieren wir mal aus.
Warum findet er das Chrome wieder nicht?
Obwohl, ich kann einfach sagen.
Ich muss Chrome doch finden, wie Lull, so, Upload, iiii, kein transparenter Hintergrund,
uuuh.
Das ist lustig.
Da unten sorgt das Browser Plugin für, dass er richtig ist.
Zum Glück habe ich das löschen schon implementiert.
Alpha Color hinzufügen, ja, das ist eine gute Idee, das ist aber ein bisschen davon
abhängig, ob die GIF Library, die ich verwende, ob die das auch kann.
Kann FFmpeg das?
Wenn FFmpeg das kann, könnten wir das selber machen.
Alpha Key hinzufügen bei GIF Animations.
FFmpeg kann fast alles, ja, das stimmt.
Ja, also ihr habt es ja wahrscheinlich schon gesehen.
Ich habe mich heute Morgen als Partner beworben bei Twitch und die haben geschrieben, das
kann zwei Wochen dauern, also haren wir mal da Dinge, ja, hoffen wir mal, dass wird alles
so funktionieren.
Heats Money, naja, komm, so viele wird es jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht geben,
weil ich habe schon am Ende, keine Ahnung, 10 Abos oder so, wobei ja Abos und Follower
auf Twitch, auf YouTube ist Abos das wichtigste, auf Twitch nennt sich das ja Follower, weil
auch Abo und so, ne.
Und außerdem abonniert man heute nicht mehr und deabonniert, das Einzige, was man macht,
ist Disabo, wenn schon, wenn schon macht man Disabo.
Warum habe ich eigentlich so ein Blödsinn hier auf meiner Shell laufen die ganze Zeit?
Warum streamst du nicht über YouTube?
Weil ich YouTube als Streaming Plattform nicht mag.
Aber Leute, wisst ihr was wir machen könnten?
Wir könnten mal auf YouTube ne Message machen, dass ich online auf Twitch bin, man kann jetzt
ja Message posten, dann wird es aber voll, dann wird es aber voll, dann müssen wir uns
hier verstecken.
Ne, mit Re-Steam, auf beiden Plattformen gleichzeitig streamen ist da auch doof.
Oh, YouTube Premium, neu, der Familientarif mit bis zu 6 Konten für YouTube und YouTube
Musik ohne Werbeanzeigen, los gehts.
Das sehe ich nur auf der anderen Seite, weil ich irgendwie keinen Werbeblocker drin habe.
Das Familienabo YouTube kostet 18 Euro im Monat, das ist ja easy money easy life für
YouTube würde ich sagen.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendjemand, der wirklich YouTube Premium hat?
Gibt es da, gibt es da irgendwen?
Ernsthaft?
Ne, Stretchy Baited oder?
Stretchy Baited Leute, ich auch Mister Milchmann, geht mir ganz genauso, die in der YouTube
App gehen die mir so auf den Sack, jedes Mal wenn du die App aufmachst, musst du wegklicken,
dass du keinen Trial machen willst, ich klick das auch immer weg, ich bin jetzt sogar so
weit, dass ich mir wirklich überlege, abends wenn ich im Bett noch ein bisschen Streams
und Videos gucken will, nicht mehr mit dem iPhone zu gucken, sondern mit einem der Android
Tablets und mir einen alternativen Client drauf zu machen.
YouTube sieht bei mir voll kaputt aus im Firefox, was ist da los?
Ach ich poste nix auf YouTube, da sind nur so viele rummische Leute am Start.
Du hast nur vergessen das Probeabort zu beenden, ja jedes Mal ey, also da spekulieren die ja
drauf, aber jedes Mal wenn ich auf YouTube gehe, ich weiß nicht, hier ist wahrscheinlich
nicht, weil Adblock und so, könnt ihr euch daran noch erinnern, Cody2012, oh Gott, das
war ja was ey, kurz danach kam die Panzerarmee von Bob, oder wie auch immer das ging, das
ist gar nicht das, wo ist Bob mit dem Panzer, ach was war das, YouTube, ne was war das,
da haben die, also als damals Google gesagt hat wir wollen jetzt Google Plus quasi Google
Plus Zwang einführen, also sprich, du musstest damals deine Accounts mit Google Plus verknüpfen,
dass du das überhaupt noch ordentlich verwenden konntest und die Leute hatten es damals schon
irgendwie im Gefühl, dass Google Plus sackt und letztendlich hat Google Plus ja auch hart
gesackt und da haben sie alle Bob und so einen Panzer gespammt, so nach dem Motto, das ist
Bob und der ist mit dem Panzer gegen Google Plus und so was haben sie damals geschrieben,
aber ich mein, wer hätte gedacht, dass das funktioniert, ne, ich hab übrigens die Suche
kaputt gemacht, die Suche geht wieder, die Suche ging letztens nicht und ich hab die Suche
nicht gefixt und die Suche geht auf einmal wieder, oder auch nicht, ich hab die Suche
doch irgendwie kaputt gemacht, wenn man einmal was falsches sucht, ist, oder auch nicht,
Monkey S darf man nicht suchen, das ist, dann gehts kaputt, aber Ayaya darf man suchen,
was findet er, wo, was auch immer ich da gebastelt hab, ja genau ID3AS, Ideas, Ideas, ID3AS, ja
das ist mir danach auch gerade gedämmert, dass es ID3AS heißen muss, Max und Englisch,
ich sag ja, wie hat der Oettinger mal erzählt, we are all sitting in one boat, in my home
country Baden-Württemberg we say we are all sitting in one boat, hat er gesagt und der
muss es wissen, ich mein, er war immerhin Digital-Kombi, wenn der das nicht weiß, dann wissen wir das
auch nicht, so Leute, also heute mal folgendes, heute ist Prime Day und wir gucken uns mal
an, ob es irgendwelche gescheiten Sachen gibt, die wir uns kaufen können, das erste, was
wir uns angucken werden ist Amazon-Gedöns, weil die letzten Male war das so, oder fast
ausschließlich so, die einzigen Sachen, die sich gelohnt haben, waren Amazon-eigene Geräte,
denn das der Fall ist ja immer schnell fertig, weil der Rest meistens einfach ultimative
Gebate war, die Dinger waren zwar günstig, aber jetzt nicht so viel günstiger, als dass
man dann ja hätte drauf warten müssen, aber die Amazon-eigenen Geräte, die sind eigentlich
immer ziemlich gut an solchen Aktionstagen, Maxmuss ist die Searchbar unten links und nicht
einfach Windows-Tastung ansuchen, weil es die Fault-Settings sind, stimmt, das geht mir
auch auf den Sack, aber nicht, viel besser, auf meinem anderen Desktop habe ich das auch
ausgeplendet, ich meine, verwendet das wirklich jemand? Gut, das muss jemand verwenden, sonst
würden sie wahrscheinlich nicht so viel Energie reinstecken, aber ich verwende das nicht,
so gut wie nie, ich verwende das nur zum Programme starten, zum Files suchen weiß ich, wo meine
Files liegen, unter Windows, unter Linux nicht, da finde ich sie aber trotzdem, ich könnte
den Stream mal auf, wenigstens mal auf Twitter posten, Leute, ich bin echt hin und her gerissen,
was meint ihr, solltet ihr mal zur Abwechslung auf YouTube eine Message schreiben, dass wir
hier mit einem Streamer am Start sind, oder sowas bleiben lassen, ich, nein, alle wollen
nicht, ja ok, dann ist gut, dann ist gut, weil ich will eigentlich auch nicht, schaut
sich überhaupt jemand die Nachrichten an, ja, ziemlich viele, da kriegst du auch Insta,
da hast du teilweise 1000 Likes drauf und so, wenn du Battlefield spielst, wann spiele
ich Battlefield, ich spiele Battlefield, wenn Bad Company 3 irgendwann mal rauskommt,
und Bad Company 3, ob es überhaupt hier mal rauskommt, angeblich ja 2020 mit der PS5,
dauert noch, es gibt YouTube nachher ja Community, kannst du auf dem Channel gucken, dann posten
wir das mal auf Twitch, nicht auf Twitch, auf Twitter posten wir das mal.
So, Tweet ist raus, Twitter ist immer so langsam, was das
anbelangt, Twitter postest in der Seite und 3 Tage später, also postest in den Link und
3 Tage später guckste und irgendwie hat er immer noch nicht den Link aktualisiert, also
diese Vorschauen Nachricht.
Was hat der Tommy hier geschrieben, by the way, ich werde jetzt anfangen eine eigene
Throne zu bauen, hab richtig Bock drauf, arbeite aktuell schon an einer Lernsimulation
mit Unity, jetzt will er es, jetzt will er es aber wissen, damit sie sich selbst stabilisiert
und Shit, vor allem und Shit, wenn ich das gelber kann, ja nice, dann GLHF, Windows Search
ist das übelste G-Bade, gibst du Foto ein, weil du Photoshop öffnen willst, erscheint
ergebnis ist er echt, bei mir nicht, bei mir findet Foto Fotos, oder Bild von meiner Katz,
eins von beiden, bei dir kommt als erstes ergebnis Paint, ja Paint, das ist auch so eine Microsoft
Taktik, das Paint wird hier offiziell gar nicht mehr unterstützt, also sagen sie ja,
Paint ist irgendwie eingestellt, aber Paint ist trotzdem immer noch dabei, er funktioniert
immer noch, und ist wahrscheinlich eines der wenigen Programme, die bei Windows mitgeliefert
ist, die über die Jahre hinweg viele Leute auch verwenden, weil die anderen Sachen, ich
meine, guck mal, jemand der ernsthaft und oft was rechnen will, ok vielleicht der Taschenrechner
noch, vielleicht der Taschenrechner noch, ja, Paint und der Taschenrechner, ja Paint 3D,
aber Paint 3D sucked, schau mal an, öh, das sieht schon so modern nicht mal an, da weiß
ich schon gar nicht, was ich machen soll, Paint 3D, ok probier mal das mal aus, also
ich mach einen Screenshot, und ich kann den Screenshot nicht einfügen, gl, oh, slacked
einfach nur, slacked, jetzt hat er den Screenshot auch eingefügt, einfach nur gedauert, ja
Screenshot kenne ich, so, und wie schneide ich jetzt hier was aus, bam, ja ok, ich gebe
zu, es ist immer noch easy mode, aber Paint 3D ist jetzt der neueste Shit, öhm, am liebsten
habe ich als Screenshot tool, eigentlich xshare unter Windows, äh, nicht xshare, jetzt
komme ich, jetzt komme ich, die mobile, alter, äh, das heißt, heißt es nicht, xshare x heißt
es nicht xshare, monka Toss, alter, xshare x heißt es, ja, ist gut, jetzt wäre man fast
auf der falschen Seite rausgekommen, huge, big brain, ne, das da, was verwende ich eigentlich
unter Windows als Screenshot tool, als Screenshot tool, ja, also ich glaube Paint und der Windows
Taschenrechner sind fast die einzigen Programme, die Super Windows dabei sind, die Leute über
die ganzen Jahre immer verwendet haben und auch weiter verwenden, weil ich mein, ernsthaft,
wirklich, meint ihr, es gibt wirklich jemand, der öfters Text editiert und Notepad verwendet,
Notepad ist der arme seligste Standard, er hat auch den Skipp, easy Notepad, ja, ganz
gut, oder was hat man hier sonst noch so drauf, Kalender, das Ding ist übelst, übelst müllig,
Windows Kalender, genauso wie das Windows Mailprogramm auch übelst der Müll ist, Truth
Music, haben sie selbst mittlerweile eingestellt, Maps, habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, weiß
gar nicht, wie das aussieht, nein, Frankfurt, I'm mine, ok, es ist wie Google Maps bloß
von Microsoft, Mixed Reality Portal, ich will Messaging, was die alles dabei haben, ich
weiß nicht, was ich damit machen soll, SMS, SMS in 2019, it can't send Text, wozu habe
ich eine, wozu habe ich noch mal genau eine Anwendung, die sich Messaging nennt, aber
keine Texte verschicken kann, das weiß auch noch Microsoft an, ist wurscht, lassen uns
heute nicht zum großen Windows Flame hinreißen, wir gucken Amazon, klar, Skype, ich habe Skype
gar nicht mehr installiert, ich habe so eine große über die Jahre hinweg, auch durch die
ganze YouTube-Geschichte, so eine große Skype-Kontakte-Liste gesammelt, wo auch tatsächlich Leute drin sind,
mit denen ich ab und zu mal schwätzen würde, aber ich will einfach Skype nicht mehr installieren.
Sag mal, hat der Nightbot schon mal was geschrieben heute?
Ja, hat er, das stimmt, das soll er nur alle 5 Minuten machen.
Wie oft passiert dir das, dass du GLRFGBaited oder Omega Poggers, na Omega Poggers sag ich
relativ selten auch in Stream, RL sagst, kommt schon öfters mal vor, das kommt schon öfters
mal vor.
Kannst du vielleicht gleich mal erzählen, was du an Software an deinem Fire Tablet hast?
Naja, also bis auf den Hut und was man dafür braucht, habe ich zusätzlich plus noch Google
Play Store, also das Google Apps Paket, Google Play Store und so eine Motion Detection App,
die quasi erkennt, wenn sich jemand dem Tablet nähert und dann entsperrt sich das automatisch.
Das funktioniert im Prinzip ganz einfach, das ist dann hinten dran ist ein Tasker-Task,
der das entsperrt, ja, aber man braucht das für Motion Detection, das ist eigentlich
ganz nice, das stellt man ein, ich weiß jetzt nicht aus dem Kopf, wie die App heißt, sonst
würde ich euch zeigen, ähm, was ist da an, ähm, doch WALL, WALL, WALL, WALL, WALL, WALL,
WALL Tablet oder so, WALL Browser, wie hieß das, wie hieß diese komische App, irgendwas
mit WALL, das ist wirklich sehr praktisch, WALL Panel, hieß das Ding WALL Panel, genau,
das ist eigentlich nur ein Browser, allerdings ist der, oder ist die Anwendung dafür entwickelt
worden, dass man das gut als, ja, als Panel an der Wand verwenden kann, sein Tablet, zum
Beispiel haben die sowas eingebaut, wie dass man automatisch, wenn sich jemand dem Tablet
nähert, wird das automatisch entlockt und solche Sachen, ja, man kann das hier einstellen,
man hat einen QR-Code-Reader dabei, falls man seinen Kühlschrank hängt, das Ding kann
sogar Face Detection machen, also sprich, das geht dann auch, wenn es unterstützt wird,
macht das Fire leider nicht, geht es dann auch automatisch an, wenn der Richtige davor
steht, noch jede Menge so praktisches Zeug, kann MQTT-Nachrichten verschicken, also hier
MQTT-Nachrichten, wenn irgendwie Motion Detection ist auf dem Tablet und sowas, ja und bei mir
macht es das, genau, bei mir sieht es dann ungefähr auch so aus, ich meine, das ist
jetzt ein Beispiel, Home Assistant Ansicht, das ist eigentlich das einzige, was da drauf
läuft, allerdings lasse ich unter der Haube, also benutze ich das hier, bloß zum Anlocken
und MQTT-Nachrichten verschicken, mein eigentliches Dashboard läuft im Chrome, nee, im Firefox,
Schwachsinn, im Firefox, weil der Chrome keine Videos richtig irgendwie unterstützt, aber
Firefox schon, weil, zum Beispiel meine ganzen Kamera-Feeds, die ich habe, also die ganzen
Kameras, das sind zwei Stück, kann Chrome nicht anzeigen, ich bin nicht ganz sicher,
warum, aber Firefox kann es, deswegen lasse ich das im Firefox laufen, ohje, Hydrogen,
jojo, also wenn ich den Lehrer habe, der in Notepad programmiert, da zweifle ich wirklich
an der Menschheit, ok, ich würde sagen, wir gucken uns jetzt mal an, was es bei Amazon
gibt, weil es steht nicht umsonst im Titel, welchen Editor benutzt du am liebsten, ja,
ich bin so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, also mein Herz, mein Herz schlägt ja eigentlich
für Vim, einfach weil ich viel in der Konsole mache, also hier, äh, warum habe ich den Scheiß
immer noch laufen, ja, also wie gesagt, mein Herz schlägt ja für Vim, ja, Maxus Vimrc,
allerdings benutze ich in letzter Zeit auch immer mehr Visual Studio Code, allerdings
benutze ich hauptsächlich Vim, allein schon dadurch, weil es halt in der Konsole läuft,
Vim ist 8, Quatsch Sebaro, Vim ist beste, das schöne ist einfach, wenn es in der Konsole
läuft, ja, wenn du sprichst, wenn du auf irgendeinem Server bist, also ich habe meinen Restplay
hier jetzt nicht an, keine Ahnung, wenn du auf irgendeinem Server bist, was haben wir
denn heute? 50, gibt es glaube ich was, ne, äh, ich kenne ja piece von meinen Restplayers
gerade nicht aus, wenn du auf einer Kiste bist, hast halt immer den Vim drauf, so, also
was haben sie denn heute schönes bei Amazon, was ist mit der Musik gerade los, ja, Nano,
Nano ist Müll, wenn schon Vim, Atom mag ich gar nicht, ich meine ich weiß im Prinzip
ist da nicht viel Unterschied zwischen Visual Studio und Atom, aber mir gefällt Visual
Studio Code besser, hallo, ist das hier der Teleshopping Kanal, ja, es gibt bestimmt
sogar irgendwo Battlefield Zeug auf Amazon, wobei, denn ich glaube den USB Stick von EA
haben wir bis heute ja nicht gekriegt, oder, du erinnerst dich noch, naja gut, also ich
habe jetzt ja, der USB Stick, der ist ein richtiger Chebat war der USB Stick, ich habe
es auch schon ein paar Mal hier im Stream erzählt, dass das eigentlich, übrigens war
hier Kocka, ich habe es jetzt auch gewagt, ne, ich habe schon ein paar Mal hier im Stream
erzählt, dass das Event an sich eigentlich ganz witzig war, wenn man halt mal wieder ein
paar Leute gesehen hat, aber dass das eigentlich einer der Gründe ist, warum ich keinen Bock
mehr habe auf irgendwie solche Sachen zu fahren, ok Leute, also jetzt gucken wir mal, was haben
sie mit Amazon, wir haben jetzt schon wieder übelst gesidetracked, 30 Minuten on, noch
nichts gemacht, genau, ey das passt doch gut oder, Partnerbewerbung, ich warte jetzt einfach,
ich warte jetzt drauf bis einer von Twitch einfach sich den Stream anguckt und dann mache
ich den übelsten Amazon Sellout und dann ist Instant Partner Promotion, easy, so machen
wir das, Strats, ja, so muss man was machen, können wir Angebote reinposten, ja, mach
mal, also man muss erstmal hier ein bisschen gucken, ob man ein zweitägiges Feuerwerk
voller toller Angebote, also ich muss ehrlich sagen, die letzten Aktionen, die es bei Amazon
gab, haben sich aus meiner Sicht nicht gelohnt, außer man möchte Amazon Geräte kaufen, deswegen
ist das erste, was wir uns angucken, die Musik ist nicht ein bisschen laut, scheint zu passen,
deswegen ist das erste, was wir uns angucken, einfach Amazon Geräte, weil so ein Fire Tablet
ist schon preisleistungsmäßig nicht schlecht, vor allem, nachdem man mittlerweile alle Fire
Tablets, 7, 8 und 10, kann man mittlerweile routen, wobei, das war jetzt wieder Anti-Amazon,
was ich erzählt habe, da wird es mit der Partnerschaft auch nichts, kritisch, übrigens Leute, ich
hab eh ein Problem, ne, ich hab wirklich ein Problem, also wenn der falsche, ich zeigs
euch mal, ich zeig euch mal was für ein Problem, das ist in der heutigen Zeit kein leichtes
Problem, also nichts, was man auf die leichte Schulter nehmen sollte, wenn die oder der
falsche meinen Partnerantrag reviewt und sich nicht den gesamten Clip anguckt, hab ich echt
ein Problem, nämlich, mein meistgesehener Clip, mein meistgesehener Clip ist das hier,
was der Knäherbär geklippt hat, wo ich aus Spaß sag bei einer Jobanzeige, dass das NWD
muss ja wohl männlich weiß deutsch sein, wer das da falsche sieht, ey, ist instant
Monkathos, engineer, guck mal, und außerdem, er hat's auch so unfähig geklippt, der Knäherbär,
genau die 4 Sekunden, wo man mir wieder was in den Mund legen kann, was überhaupt nicht
stimmt, passt mal auf, engineer, weiß männlich deutsch, das passt doch, Ben, fertig, das
was ich danach gesagt hab, ist überhaupt nicht mehr drin, das ist wirklich, und es hat auch
80 Views, alles andere hat 20 oder 15 oder so, danach sag ich ja auch noch erstens, wie
es richtig heißt, und zweitens, dass das einfach so ein bisschen Leute triggern war, oder komm
so, in der heutigen Zeit ist sowas, ey, wo sich wirklich jeder über jedes aufregt,
und die Leute teilweise schon gebannt werden irgendwo, weil man vermutet, sie haben was
falsches gesagt, Leute, Professoren von der Uni gekickt werden, weil sie irgendwie was
zweideutiges gesagt haben, da muss man echt aufpassen, ja, alles nur ausreden, die Wahrheit
kommt früher oder später raus, aber ich weiß nicht was, der geht fort mit dem Clip, wie
kannst du den Clip, ne, also wenn's so weit kommen sollte, ernsthaft, also wenn's wirklich
so weit kommen sollte, dass ich Probleme krieg, wegen 4 Sekunden, die komplett aus dem Zusammenhang
gerissen sind, dann sind wir, da sind wir so von Gedanken, Polizei und etwas merkwürdigen
Vorstellungen, wie sich die Welt entwickelt, nicht mehr weit entfernt, ja, also, das kann's
nicht sein, jetzt muss ich einfach jemanden, den kompletten, die kompletten 30 Sekunden
angucken, dann wird er auch sehen, um was es im Kontext eigentlich ging, ich hab Zeug gelabert
hab halt, wie man das macht im Stream, so, aber jetzt Amazon, also Amazon Geräte, das
sind nämlich die Dinger, die sich am meisten lohnen, oftmals, gel Amazon, falls einer zuguckt,
ja, also Amazon Geräte, Sellout Activated, also, also was sich tatsächlich lohnt, ist,
sind die Fire Tablets, wo gibts denn die 10er, ich find die 10er sind die besten, also wenn
man sowas machen wie ich, als, als, als Panel an der Wand verwenden, wozu Amazon Geräte
kaufen Easypie mit Alexa drauf und Gumbelmick dran, weil das ein schöneres Komplettpaket
ist, ähm, äh, äh, Leute, ich seh grad ihr postet Links, wenn ihr Links postet, müsst
ihr die unbedingt, also Links zu Amazon angeboten, müsst ihr die unbedingt mit Ed Wupplors posten,
weil nur wenn ihr die mit Ed Wupplors postet, kommt das in mein Chatlog Tool mit rein, wenn
das nicht in mein Chatlog Tool mit reinkommt, überseh ichs wahrscheinlich, ok, also Amazon
Geräte wasser mann, sie sparen 40€, also das ganze Amazon Alexa Echo Zeug juckt mich
null, sind die Links im Tool schon klickbar, ich glaube nicht, äh, aber ich mein, Copy
Paste und zur Seite wechseln, das krieg ich, das geht noch, ah, kennst du eine gute Schriftart
für Twitch Chat, hack, hack ist die beste Schriftart für alles, hackfont, beste, dafont.com
hackfont, beste, hackfont, also ich mein, das ist jetzt kein Witz, ne, ich find das wirklich
gut, allerdings für Text, allerdings für Text an sich, würde ich vielleicht was anderes
nehmen, ich weiß nichts, keine Ahnung, aber hack, beste, also Echo und so interessiert
mich überhaupt nicht, weil ich hab keinerlei Alexa bei mir am Start, ich persönlich bin
auch jemand, ich hab schon im Stream öfters gesagt, ich seh für mich den Vorteil von
Voice Assistant Geschichten nicht, es sei denn, man fährt viel Auto und wills halt von
dort verwenden und hat halt seine Hände nicht dafür, um halt irgendwas zu tippen, das ist
ok, lasse ich mir gefallen, aber ansonsten bin ich kein großer Fan von Voice Assistant,
weil ich einfach der Meinung bin, ich kann alles schneller und direkter erledigen mit
Maus im Tastatur oder eben mit Sachen direkt auf dem Tablet und ich hab kein Bock mehr
mit Mikrofon in der Wohnung stehen zu haben und bisher haben sie es alle verkackt, alles
haben sie verkackt, ich weiß nicht ob ihr es gelesen habt, es kam erst letztens wieder
die Meldung raus, dass Google nicht nur die Dinge aufzeichnet, sondern dass die Dinge
auch ausgewertet werden und nicht etwa automatisiert ausgewertet werden, sondern dass die, dass
die, wie nennt man es so schön, transkribiert werden, also dass dann irgendein Chineser im
Container da sitzt, wahrscheinlich machen sich auch irgendwelche Crowdsourcing Geschichten,
die werden wahrscheinlich immer richtig bezahlt die Leute, dass irgendein Chineser im Container
da sitzt und quasi dann der Deutsch kann, also deutscher Chineser im Keller, ergibt
irgendwie wenig Sinn, dass dann wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Leiharbeiter oder so, wahrscheinlich
muss es billig sein, den Kram übersetzen und dass sie auch explizit darauf achten sollen,
auch sowas wie Hintergrundgeräusche, Stimmung der Leute und sowas genau zu beschreiben.
Nächster Clip ey, jetzt gehts schon wieder los, zumindest wenn ich sowas schon höre
und das haben sie ja alle, alle Voice Assistent Anbieter verkackt, hab ich ehrlich gesagt
keinen Bock. Wenn ich mir's aussuchen müsste, wem von diesen ganzen Läden ich noch am ehesten
vertraue, also quasi Google, Microsoft, Apple oder Amazon, da ist es bei mir mittlerweile
so, also was, was, ähm, was so Datensicherheit und Privacy und sowas angeht, da ist Google
bei mir ganz unten, den traue ich Null, danach kommt Apple, den traue ich auch Null, bei Apple
ist immer alles so super secret und du hast überhaupt keine Ahnung was da einschwind genau
passiert, danach kommt Amazon und am meisten traue ich mittlerweile ehrlich gesagt hauptsächlich
auch durch ihr, durch ihr ganzes Cloud-Gedöns und weil sie auch ein bisschen was zu verlieren
haben an Microsoft, allerdings traue ich keinem so weit, dass ich mir einen Voice Assistent
von denen daheim hinstellen würde. Eher Google oder eher Facebook? Das ist jetzt, also wenn
ich mich wirklich entscheiden müsste zwischen Google oder Facebook, dann würde ich Google
nehmen, weil Facebook finde ich als Plattform an sich schon so unglaublich kacke, dass ich
viel einfacher ohne Facebook leben kann als ohne Google. Microsoft sind auch die einzigen
davon die noch keinen größeren Skandal hatten, ich weiß, ich weiß, deswegen und Apple gibt
sich in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen besonders Datenschutz bezogen, aber letztendlich traue
ich keinem davon so richtig, ist ja auch egal, kann ja jeder machen was er will, ich meine
Google und Amazon hatten da schon ihre Skandale, was mit Alexa gemacht wird, es gibt natürlich
auch genug Leute die sagen es ist mir egal, das ist ja auch eine legitime Ansicht, es
gibt genug Leute die sagen es ist mir egal, zumindest ich bin aus zweierlei Gründen halt
eben der Meinung ich brauche keinen Alexa, das liegt zum ersten daran, weil ich der Ansicht
bin, ich kann alles außer vielleicht beim Autofahren schneller machen, mit Maustastatur
oder eben Touch-Eingaben und ich will kein Mikrofon in der Wohnung stehen haben der Zeugs
aufnimmt, zumindest keinen der nicht von mir ist. Ok weiter, Fire TV Stick, das ist an
sich ein ziemlich cooles Produkt, wenn man keinen Smart TV hat oder keinen Shield TV
oder sowas dran hat oder keine andere Android Box schon dran hat, die Fire Sticks sind gut,
ich weiß nicht ob man die aktuellen Fire Sticks flashen kann, ne habe ich nicht, habe
Siri auch ausgeschaltet, aber komplett, ich habe die komplette Voice Bedienung vom iPhone
ausgeschaltet, ja das Shield TV hat auch eine Google Assistant in der Fernbedienung,
allerdings ist der ausgeschaltet und der geht wirklich nur auf Knopfdruck und das ist auch
insofern nachvollziehbar, weil das Ding mit einer popeligen Batterie läuft und wenn das
wirklich ein Mikrofon hätte, was permanent an wäre, dann wäre das Ding nach drei Wochen
leer. Ich habe ein iPhone, ich habe alles mögliche eigentlich an mobilen Geräten,
ich habe ein iPhone als Smartphone, ich hatte mal kurzzeitig letztens, so als zum testen,
ein OnePlus, was war das vorletzte OnePlus, 5 ne, 7 ist das aktuelle, 6, 5, ich glaube
5 war was, hatte ich mal ganz kurz zum ausprobieren, da fand ich auch ein praktisches Teil, also
ich hatte jetzt nichts vom Anfassen her irgendwie daran auszusetzen, allerdings bei mir ist es
relativ einfach, ich habe ein iPhone, weil das iPhone von der Firma gesponsert ist und
inklusive, inklusive Vertrag dabei, also ich wäre eigentlich bescheuert, wenn ich mir noch
ein anderes Handy holen würde, dafür habe ich auch an Tablets alles mögliche, was es
gibt, Android Tablets und ein iPad und Tablets haben wir hier wirklich mittlerweile, da kannst
du, da kannst du dir Häuschen draus bauen, so eine Gartenhütte kannst du dir aus den
Tablets bauen mittlerweile, es sind mittlerweile wahrscheinlich 11 Tablets oder sowas und wirklich
verwendet davon wird eigentlich bloß das Shield Tablet verwende ich ganz gerne noch,
das iPad wird oft verwendet und die zwei Amazon Tablets und das Asus Tablet, der Rest ist
eigentlich einfach nur da und leer und gammelt rum und die Sache ist halt einfach die für
Heimautomatisierungs Sachen, habe ich schon oft im Stream gesagt, wenn man ein bisschen
was automatisieren will und ein bisschen was automatisch machen will eignet sich Android
einfach viel besser als iOS, Apple hat da ein bisschen komische Policies, das ändert
sich aber jetzt mit 13, mit 13 gibt es jetzt zum ersten mal die Möglichkeit, habe ich
gesehen, dass man, wir werden ein bisschen Side-Tracked gerade, aber egal, das ist ein
interessantes Thema finde ich, mit iOS 13 gibt es zum ersten mal die Möglichkeit, dass
man Shortcuts zeitbasiert, ne, Timer, weiß gar nicht was ich da suchen muss, ja genau,
man kann jetzt nämlich und das ist, ich glaube die meisten Leute realisieren gar nicht was
für ein riesen Fortschritt das für iOS ist oder für alle Leute, die ein bisschen mehr
machen wollen mit iOS oder ein paar Sachen automatisch machen wollen, das ist eine riesen
Verbesserung, bisher war es halt einfach so, du konntest Sachen nicht automatisch auf iOS
ausführen, das ging nicht, das hat alles eine User Aktion erfordert, das ist Policy von
Apple, genauso wenig konntest du Sachen im Hintergrund laufen lassen oder nur nur sehr
eingeschränkt, mittlerweile geht das, wenn nämlich iOS 13 rauskommt, ja Dark Mode auch,
haben sie mittlerweile, ok das ist ein bisschen beknackt beschrieben hier, genau, mittlerweile
kannst du nämlich Shortcuts, Shortcuts ist bei iOS das eingebaute Taskger ist das, das
eingebaute Taskger nur in, nicht ganz so ausführlich, aber mittlerweile kannst du auch ziemlich
viel, eigentlich alles mitmachen was du machen willst, bloß halt nichts im Hintergrund
laufen lassen und, ja du kannst bei Android auch ungeroutet auch sau viel ohne User Aktion
machen, zumindest kann man jetzt in iOS 13, kann man Shortcuts triggern lassen durch Airplane
Mode juckt mich nicht, Alarm ist ganz interessant, wenn man Kalendereintrag hat, aber das wirklich
interessante, achso, ich komme beispielsweise in der Arbeit an, gehe daheim weg, aber das
wirklich interessante ist Time of Day und ich glaube viele Leute realisieren gar nicht
was das für ein riesen Fortschritt ist im Vergleich zu bisher, weil jetzt ist es so,
ich glaube man kann minutengenau, kann man Tasks triggern lassen ohne User Aktion die
im Hintergrund laufen, das ist übelst nice, das war nicht möglich auf iOS bisher und es
ist nicht so, nicht möglich, allerdings mit Gefrickel doch gehts irgendwie halbwegs, nein
das war von Apple so nicht gewollt, kannst du ein Beispiel dafür machen, ja du kannst
zum Beispiel nachgucken, alle Minute kannst du nachgucken ob irgendwie ein Ereignis eingetreten
ist, zum Beispiel dass jemand geklingelt hat und dann machst du automatisch den VLC auf
mit dem Kamerabild drinnen, das war vorher nicht möglich unter iOS, das ging nicht,
du konntest dir die Haare ausreißen, das ging nicht, das einzige was du bisher machen
konntest, ähnlich wie ein Grondjob, ja ist es im Endeffekt, das einzige was du unter
iOS bisher machen konntest ist, du konntest das um Umwege machen, allerdings nicht komplett
automatisch, du konntest dir ne Nachricht schicken lassen, ne Push Nachricht aufs Handy
und die Push Nachricht musstest du dann aufmachen, musstest dann anklicken und dann konntest
du mit nem Callback Link VLC mit dem Kamera Feed öffnen, du hast ja immer ne User Aktion
gebraucht, sowas was du jetzt machen kannst ist halt, du checkst ist was passiert und
reagierst automatisch drauf, du kannst ja auch einstellen, dass dein iPad alle Minute
oder alle 5 Minuten irgendeinen Stato setzt in deinem halben Automatisierungssystem, ja
du kannst zum Beispiel dir ne Nachricht anzeigen lassen automatisch, oder irgendwas automatisch
starten lassen auf deinem iPad oder was auch immer, irgendwas, also Sachen die keine User
Interaktion brauchen kannst du jetzt machen, das ging die ganze Zeit nicht, was immer noch
nicht richtig geht ist Anwendungen zu starten, aber das geht unter Android auch nicht, du
kannst nur Anwendungen starten die sich explizit dafür registriert haben gestartet zu werden,
aber das reicht ja schonmal, besser als nix, aber das ist wirklich nen riesen Fortschritt
für iOS, so, so viel jetzt erstmal dazu, jetzt haben wir uns ein bisschen vom Thema
wegbewegt, aber das ist wirklich nen riesen Unterschied, nein gibt es nicht, ähm, äh,
Generator Mortimer, stimmt das, wie ich das ausgesprochen habe, es gibt, äh, es gibt
nen MQTT Client, der ist allerdings dafür gedacht, dass du dich mit der App zu nem MQTT
Server verbindest, es gibt keinen MQTT Client, der im Hintergrund läuft, dem du Nachrichten
schicken kannst, sondern darauf reagierst, das geht jetzt auch noch nicht mit 13, du
kannst allerdings mit 13 jede Minute nachgucken lassen, ob was passiert ist, genauer als ne
Minute gehts leider, leider nicht, mit Android und Tasker ist das überhaupt kein Ding, da
kannst du nämlich sowas machen, da kriegst du sofort, beispielsweise kannst du die ganzen,
die ganzen Tablets, die ich hier hab, die ganzen, äh, Wall, ähm, ganzen Panels für
meine Heimautomatisierung, da hab ich zum Beispiel so gemacht, dass das zentral gesteuert
mit allen anderen Displays und Sachen, dass zum Beispiel sowas, ähm, dass um 22 Uhr die
Lautstärke wird automatisch runter geregelt, die Bildhelligkeit wird automatisch runter
geregelt, so Dinger, das kannst du zentral machen, das kannst du mit allen anderen vergessen,
bis jetzt und je nachdem, was Apple noch unterstützt, na gut, ähm, aber nichtsdestotrotz, die Firesticks
sind ne gute Alternative dafür, wenn man eben kein Smartphone hat oder, äh, kein,
jetzt mach ich Schwachsinn, äh, kein Smart TV hat oder wenn man eben keine andere Android
Box drauf hat, die sind relativ günstig und ich glaube, die kann man mittlerweile auch
flashen, da bin ich mir aber nicht ganz sicher, zumindest sind die auch an Hardware-Decodern
und so ganz gut, also da gibt es nichts dagegen zu sagen, generell ist die Amazon Hardware
wirklich nice, die sie haben, Echo Show brauch ich auch nicht, so ein Paperwhite Kindle hab
ich, aber leider, ist es da ja immer noch so, dass die Dinger hauptsächlich dafür da
sind Amazon eigene, Amazon-Dinger anzuzeigen, also sprich, die man bei Amazon kauft und
ich kauf nicht so viel Lese-Kram über Amazon, dass ich das gelohnt hätte, ähm, Echo Speaker
brauch ich auch nicht, hier wirds schon interessanter, sparen sie 50€ Fire HD 10, das kostet normalerweise
glaube ich 150€ oder so, was, sparen sie 50€ Fire HD 10, sparen sie 50€, das eine
ist, das eine ist, äh, ach das eine ist 64G und das andere ist 32G, gut 32G reichen auch
dick aus, da auch nichts, hier kann man Firesticks auch routen, ja, man kann, also man kann aktuell
alle Tablets routen, hab ich gesehen, das ist ein Angebot, das lohnt sich, also wenn
man, wenn man Verwendung dafür hat, ich mein, das blödeste was man natürlich machen kann
ist sinnlos den, den Kram irgendwie kaufen, wenn man einfach nur sagt, oh das ist günstig,
äh, lass, lass mal holen, bringt natürlich nix, wenn man damit jetzt irgendwas vor hat,
wenn man, oder wenn man einen Anwendungszweck für hat, dann würd ichs jetzt kaufen, weil
99€ ist für das Tablet wirklich guter Preis, ach geht das mittlerweile, Träve, ja, und
selbst wenn man es nicht routet, man kann relativ einfach, ähm, zum Beispiel auch nen
anderen Launcher drauf machen und sowas, falls man keinen Bock auf dieses Amazon Zeug hat,
allerdings, man kanns auch ohne Probleme eins zu eins so verwenden, wie es von Amazon kommt,
das ist ein wirklich nice Tablet, das einzige was mir in dem Default ein bisschen fehlt
ist, mal davon abgesehen, das haben die Werbung ein bisschen auf dem Kick-Skill, aber das
einzige was mir fehlt ist ein Google Play Store, das heißt, den würd ich eigentlich
immer nachinstallieren, weil der Amazon Play Store ist jetzt bei weitem nicht so das, aber
ich mein, wir wären hier kein Science and Technology Stream, wenn wir Geräte so verwenden
würden, wie sich das der Hersteller denkt, ne, aber das Sebaro hat nen Ref Link gemacht,
oder haben wir den schon länger, den Ref Link, krasser Shit, äh, wusste ich gar nicht,
was für nen Ref Link, was soll ich sagen, gibt's, ok, nochmal schnell die anderen,
das ist wirklich Big Brain vom Sebaro hier, ach, wir sind ja heute just Chatting, stimmt,
wir sind ja gar nicht Technology, ok, mal schnell durchgucken, was haben wir, also, wenn
man Tablet braucht, das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall für 99 Euro, da kann man nichts verkehrt
machen, als nächstes, die ganzen Fire Tablets lohnen sich, die ganzen Fire Tablets lohnen
sich, ähm, brauch ich net, da hab ich meine China Cam dran, das reicht, wüsste ich gar
nicht, dass die Ring-Geschichten mittlerweile auch Amazon sind, ok, brauch ich alles nicht,
ja, gut, also, die Tablets lohnen sich auf jeden Fall, ok, gucken wir mal, was, äh,
was die Leute hier geschickt haben, ähm, OnePlus 6 Smartphone, zum Smartphone preisen
kann ich überhaupt nichts sagen, ist das gut, gucken wir mal, Geiz Gals, was ist das, die
Variante mit 128G, ja, das erscheint mir ein ziemlich guter Preis zu sein, ja, kann
man machen, jetzt net sehr vorsichtig mit den Links, Monkathos, na, auf Amazon würde
ich mal von ausgehen, auf Amazon gibt es nicht so viel, wo Monka Tost wird, außerdem guck
ich mir den Krams auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, soweit es geht vorher schon mal an, ähm, also
das macht einen echt guten Eindruck, ich weiß nicht, persönlich brauchst du nicht, aber
ich finde es nice, wie groß ist denn das, 6,28 Zoll, wie groß ist denn meins, ist es
ein 6 oder ein 6S, woran erkenne ich denn, ob ich einen 6 oder einen 6S habe, steht das
hinten drauf, an mir steht hinten nur iPhone drauf, vielleicht die Modellnummer, beim S
steht S, ne, dann ist es nur ein iPhone 6, wie groß ist denn ein iPhone 6, 4,7 Zoll,
ok, dann ist das hier in der ganze Ecke größer, wie es aussieht, ne, das da, das da, das
ist dann massive dagegen, ja, aber ich werde ja früher oder später in den Genuss, eigentlich
will ich gar nicht so richtig, ich habe jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten, das iPhone 6 komplett
mit einer Hand zu bedienen, aber ich werde jetzt ja demnächst, nächste Woche oder übernächste
Woche in den Genuss eines iPhone, wie heißen die Dinger jetzt, S, X, XS, ah was auch immer,
in den Genuss eines neuen iPhones kommen, weil sie sich bei uns überlegt haben auf
der Arbeit, ähm, wir brauchen mal neue Handys, so, aber das sieht preisleistungsmäßig wirklich
ziemlich gut aus, wenn ich das vergleiche mit den anderen Seiten, so was haben wir sonst
auch hier, WD Green SSD 10G, boah das ist aber billig, weiß nicht was die sonst kostet,
aber für 20 Euro kann man da wahrscheinlich nicht viel verkehrt machen, naja, die kostet
vor allem auch 20 Euro, aber für 20 Euro kann man allgemein nicht allzu viel verkehrt
machen, ich würde noch nicht mal sagen Skamars, es ist halt echt günstig, aber was haben wir
noch mal, WD Red interessant, oh ja, oh, das ist ziemlich gut, was kostet die denn normalerweise,
ja nur, also für mich ist es ein Vorteil 5400 RPM, weil in der Regel sind Platten mit 5400
RPM, also wenn man die einfach nur als Speicher verwenden will, ähm, ja, oh nice, die glaube
die hole ich mir, glaub die hole ich mir, easy, äh, bloß mal einen neuen, neuen Ordner
machen, ähm, oh wie hat man den Mist jetzt hier noch mal eingeblendet, Lesezeichen, Lesezeichenleiste,
Lesezeichenleiste, äh, neuer Ordner, Prime, wie kriege ich den neuen Ordner jetzt hier
vorne hin, so wahrscheinlich, fuck, Prime, das ist, das finde ich echt gut, also aktuell
habe ich ja, ähm, 3 10TB, allerdings habe ich, äh, Einwurf 10TB, die habe ich dreimal
dran, oh die ist aber auch eine ganze Ecke günstiger geworden, aber immer noch, immer
noch viel teurer, als die hier, da habe ich aktuell 3 Stück dran, ZFS RAID 1, was im Prinzip
ähnlich ist wie ein RAID 5, was mit Importgebühren, wieso Importgebühren, ach das ist weltweiter
Versand, verkauft durch Amazon Global, ach so Moment, was würde, ich teste mal kurz
auf dem zweiten Monitor, das seht ihr jetzt nicht, mit meinem Amazon Account, was es denn
kosten würde, wenn man den Kram wirklich, wirklich bestellt, weil nicht, dass wir uns
da verwirren lassen, durch den Preis, der eigentlich ganz günstig aussieht, aber es
vielleicht gar nicht ist, man weiß ja nie, gucken, zur Kasse gehen, 250 würde das kosten,
kann diese Adresse versenden, Bank Einzug, ja, ach nee, das zieht er sogar wieder, Moment,
Gutschein eingelöst, was zum Teufel, was für ein Gutschein, warum habe ich den 56
Euro Gutschein gekriegt, ich glaube, das ist eine Amazon interne Geschichte, ich glaube,
das ist eine Amazon interne Geschichte, dass das wieder stimmt, was hier steht, als Preis,
ja, also wenn ich, also ich bin jetzt auf dem Bildschirm, wo ich die Bestellung abschicken
kann, und er sagt mir, ich kriege es geliefert, 9. August, warte, das dauert noch eine ganze
Weile, 9. August, also 9. bis 13. August, und es kostet mich 239,24, das ist echt billig,
das ist echt billig für eine 10TB Platte, das kann man mal machen, ja, ich würde sagen,
gleich mal 5 bestellen, ne, also ich werde mir wenn überhaupt eine bestellen, und weil
es irgendwo jemand gerade gesagt hat, 5400 RPM, in meinem Fall finde ich sogar gut, wenn
ich nur 5400 RPM hatte, ich hätte mir damals auch gerne welche gekauft mit 5400 RPM, aus
zwei Gründen, erstens, weil die meisten ein bisschen stromsparender sind, und zweitens,
ne, eigentlich drei Gründe, zweitens, weil sie nicht so laut sind, und drittens, äh,
Moment, drittens, aber warum habe ich die Platte nochmal gekauft, Big Brain gerade wieder
angesagt, weil sie nicht so warm werden, genau, weil sie nicht so warm werden, Max, wie sieht
es aus mit der Twitch Partner Bewerbung, so sieht es aus, ja, und, ähm, ich meine, ich
habe die zwar alle, in diesem, ich habe euch das Greusier mal gezeigt, gibt es ja sogar
ein, gibt es ja sogar ein komplettes Video drüber mit den Platten, na, da, hier, das
schubbe ich sie her, aber im Prinzip sieht die Kiste immer noch so aus, ähm, da ist,
da ist der Einschub für die Platten, und hier habe ich halt 13 Terabyte Platten drinnen,
also man sieht, die sind in einem ordentlichen Gehäuse drinnen, mit ordentlicher Lüftung,
ich habe hier auch jede Menge, hier war es noch nicht komplett ausgebaut, ich habe hier
hinten zwei Noctua Lüfter drinnen und hier vorne auch noch einer, also das Ding ist
schon ordentlich, ähm, gedingst, ja, durchlüftet, und, aber die Platten werden trotzdem ziemlich
warm, wofür braucht man so viel Speicher, ja, also Punkt 1 ist erstmal Speicher haben,
ist immer besser als kein Speicher haben, also so viel dazu, das ist, 900 IQ Play, der
nächste Punkt ist, 10 Terabyte geht ja davon eh schon mal weg, wie gesagt, es ist in ZFS
Rate 1, das bedeutet, es bleiben von 30 Terabyte eh nur noch 20 Terabyte drüber, also sind
wir schon mal auf 20 runter, davon geht ein bisschen für die Verwaltung von ZFS und Gedöntstroph,
also unterm Strich, würde ich sagen, hat man so, sagen wir mal 18 Terabyte, 18 Terabyte,
und 18 Terabyte kriegt man relativ schnell voll, ähm, also ich habe jetzt auch gemerkt
im Nachhinein, dass es für mich ein bisschen oversized ist, aber es ist nicht so, als würde
ich es gar nicht voll kriegen, also in den Zeiten, wo ich noch ein bisschen öfters Videos
auf YouTube gemacht habe, und ich auch etwas öfters Gameplay aufgenommen habe, da habe
ich genau sowas gebraucht, wo man die Gameplays, die man vorsortiert hat, einfach mal in Ruhe
aus nass schieben kann, und dann verwenden kann, wenn man sie braucht, aktuell verwende
ich die Dinge hauptsächlich eben ganz normal als Fileserver und vor allem als Backup Kiste
für meinen Desktop und für den Streaming Rechner und für das Notebook unten und teilweise
auch für Sachen auf dem Server drauf, Backups von den Raspberries, weil die ja ganz gerne
mal kaputte Micro SD Karten haben, ähm, es ist nach wie vor wahnsinnig oversized, ja,
aber es ist jetzt nicht irgendwie 10 mal mehr als ich brauchen würde oder so, es ist halt
einfach nur gut bemessen aktuell 18TB, aber man kriegt das schon voll. Kannst du eine
leise HD empfehlen? Also was richtig leise ist, sind die WD-Green-Dinger, die hörste
fast gar nicht. Was benutzt du als OS auf deinem NAS? Ne, das ist ja nicht nur ein NAS,
da ist ein Ubuntu-Server drauf, der noch viele andere Dinge auch macht und da ist einfach
ein Ubuntu-Server mit einem Samba drauf und fertig. Unten drunter ist ZFS, aber das Angebot
finde ich, warum ist das so teuer wieder, ah jetzt, das Angebot finde ich echt gut,
ich glaube da bestelle ich mir nachher eine, einfach weil es geht und weil das ein gutes
Angebot ist. Das gefällt mir wirklich, also das ist wirklich mein Angebot, kann ich sagen,
ist nice. Das gefällt mir. So, ähm, habe ich noch irgendwas übersehen? Netzwerk-Komponenten.
Achja, irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich zufrieden bin mit meinem 10G-Switch, ne, ist derjenige
noch da? Docker oder LXC? Kommt auch an, was man machen will, ich habe beides laufen,
mein, die ganze Home Assistant-Heimautomatisierungsgeschichte ist Docker, das sind aber halt schon fertig
gepackte Anwendungen, deswegen ist Docker, alle anderen Sachen, die ich ein bisschen
isolieren will sind LXC, beziehungsweise eigentlich diese Ubuntu-LXD-Geschichte. Und ja, ich bin
sehr zufrieden mit meinem 10G-Switch, allerdings genauso wie bei dem 30TB NAS, auch im Nachhinein
sehr over-sized das Ganze, allerdings war mir das im Vorfeld ja schon klar, das war eher
so eine Sache, weil es geht. Ihr müsst, ihr müsst, wenn ihr Links postet mit Amazon, übrigens
heute sind nur Amazon-Links erlaubt, ne, also wenn heute denkt, jemand das ausnutzen zu
müssen und wieder irgendwelche komischen Porn-Seiten postet, dann wird das Ebaro gleich mal wieder
eine Runde bannen. Die müsst ihr mit Adwoblos posten, weil sonst tauchen sie in meinem Mit-Log-Tool
nicht auf. Netzwerk-Komponenten sollen wir uns angucken, ok. Aber wie gesagt, mit meinem
10G-Switch bin ich echt zufrieden, das ist der hier. Also wenn man einen 10G-Switch braucht,
kann ich den wirklich empfehlen. Ja, das ist ja so eine Zeichnung. Ansonsten, wenn ihr
euch nicht sicher seid, ob ihr einen 10G-Switch braucht, dann braucht ihr keinen 10G-Switch.
Aber der ist, der ist wirklich gutes Ding. 12FSP+, Glasfaser-Ports und 4 10G-Kupfer-Ports.
Und auch ansonsten ist die Oberfläche und was man alles machen kann recht gut. Wie teuer
ist der Switch? Ja gut. Muss da schon 500€ für ausgeben. Brauchst du den wirklich?
Ne, wie gesagt, ich hab ja gesagt, das ist relativ, relativ oversized für mich, aber
das war mir schon klar. Aber es hat, es hat wirklich was, wenn man über das Netzwerk
Sachen mit 800MB schieben kann. Leider nur kurz. Ich mein, die 3x10T-Platten sind zwar
relativ schnell, allerdings 800MB die Sekunde auf Dauer kriegen sie auch nicht gebacken.
Aber das speichert erstmal ein bisschen was im RAM und sobald das dann im RAM ist und
auf die Platte geschrieben wird, dann geht die Übertragungsrate auch ein bisschen runter
auf, auf keine Ahnung, 400, 450MB oder sowas. Aber es ist trotzdem nice, 500MB über das
Netzwerk zu schieben. Also pro Sekunde. Man könnte auch noch eine SSD als Buffer reinschmeißen,
genau. Okay, also wir sollen uns mal, hat jemand gepostet, wer hat denn gepostet, Netzwerk?
Der Morris hat geschrieben, wir sollen uns mal Netzwerkkomponenten angucken. Okay, schauen
wir mal, was es da so gibt. TP-Link. USB-Pluto-Setup, okay. WLAN-Repeater brauchen die wenigsten
Leute eigentlich. Netgear 8-Port-Switch über 30. Weil man noch einen weiteren Switch braucht.
Generell bei so unmanaged Switchen, oh das ist ein Smart-Managed, was ist denn an dem
Managed? Smart-Managed, hat er eine Web-Interface oder was ist an dem Managed? Achja, hier,
einfache Konfiguration mittels Browser. Das ist ja schonmal ein dick besserer Switch anscheinend.
Kann er PoE? PoE kann er. Ey, der ist gar nicht schlecht. Da sind wieder die Noobs am
Werk, er. Es ist ein Switch, er ist solide verarbeitet, er kommt nicht mit dem VoIP-Netz
einer Fritzboxer. Was hat denn der Switch mit irgendeinem Fritzbox-VoIP-Netz zu tun?
Das ist Strom über, Strom über das Netzwerkkabel. Ist nicht so einfach, wie es sich anhört,
es gibt wieder zig verschiedene Standards, wie das so sein muss. Der verbreitetste dürfte
48 Volt, ach keine Ahnung, müsst ihr nachgucken. Oder alternativ auch Pass-of-Exile, genau.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, für 29,90 macht das Ding hier keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Es hat acht Ports, es kann so die Basics-Sachen wie QoS und WLAN, äh WLAN, nicht WLAN, WLAN
kann er nicht. Was für SFP-Plus-Module hast du in deinem Switch? Äh, ich hab zwei, ich
hab einmal die billigen Mikrotik-Module und die offiziellen Ubiquiti-Module. Ich kann
dir aber grad nicht sagen, wie die Dinger genau heißen. Ich hab's doch mal irgendwo
auf Twitter geschrieben, vielleicht finden wir das. Ne, keine Ahnung. Zumindest hab
ich zwei. Billigen von Mikrotik funktionieren und die offiziellen von Ubiquiti funktionieren
auch. Aber den Switch finde ich echt ganz cool. Ich meine, ich persönlich würde mir
lieber, wenn ich viele Ports brauche, würde ich mir lieber einen 24-Port-Mikrotik-Switch
zum Beispiel kaufen. Damit kannst du mehr machen, der ist preisleistungsmäßig auch
ziemlich gut. Aber wenn man einfach nur so einen Switch zur Erweiterung braucht und Verwendung
für sowas hier hat, wenn man beispielsweise WLAN einsetzt, ist das eine gute Sache. Allerdings,
wenn es so ein Erweiterungs-Switch ist, den man sich beispielsweise am Schreibtisch stellt
oder so, dann ist es meistens sogar wurscht, ob der selbst WLAN supportet oder nicht, weil
man am Schreibtisch ja im Endeffekt dann nur ein WLAN verwendet und dann muss das Gerät
auch kein WLAN können. Wie sehr ist ein Fire-TV-Stick zu empfehlen? Ich finde die Dinger gut, also
wenn du kein Smart-TV hast oder mit deinem nicht zufrieden bist oder keine andere Android-TV-Box,
ich finde die Fire-TV-Sticks gut. Du musst aber mal ein bisschen gucken, was es so viele
Möglichkeiten gibt da an Custom-Firmware und solche Geschichten. Habe ich mich nicht beschäftigt,
weil ich habe seit ein paar Jahren ein Shield-TV, bin ich auch sehr zufrieden mit. Unter der
Haube ist beides ja ein Android. Aber überall wo man was zum Thema Fire-TV-Sticks liest,
sind die Dinger immer recht, schneiden die immer recht gut ab. Was ist der Unterschied
zwischen einem Fire-TV-Stick und einem Raspberry-Pie? Dass die Sachen auf einem Fire-TV-Stick viel
weicher laufen als auf einem Raspberry-Pie. Der Fire-TV-Stick hat Hardware, Hardware H264
und ich glaube auch H265-Decoder. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, du hast auf jeden Fall
jede Menge Hardware-Decoder und eine 3D-beschleunigte Oberfläche. Weicher? Nein, ich meine, dass
es weniger ruckelt. Nicht bei der Wiedergabe von Videos unbedingt, sondern beim
Bedienen von der Oberfläche. Man müsste mal gucken, wie er sich gegen den Raspberry-Pie
viel schlägt, weil der hat auch ein paar Sachen mehr. Aber mit einem Fire-Stick kannst
du nichts verkehrt machen. Was hat der gekostet? 29 Euro. Da gibt es nichts, was du... Wir
haben 200 Zuschauer. Alter, Poggers. Nice, sehr schön. Qt-Chat. Qt-IF. Aber wenn man
einfach nur einen Switch braucht und eventuell tatsächlich Verwendung für WLAN an seinem
Schreibtisch hat, weil, sag mal so, du wirst den ja hier wahrscheinlich, wird man den nicht
unbedingt als den zentralen Switch verwenden, wo man die WLANs darauf verwaltet, sondern
eher als Erweiterung am Schreibtisch, dann macht das echt einen ganz guten Eindruck,
das Ding hier. Vor allem für den Preis. Für den Preis kann man eh nicht so viel verkehrt
machen. Acht Ports, Gigabits, ein paar advancedere Features, das macht einen guten Eindruck,
das Ding. Und die Platte erst recht. Die Platte ist absolut POG. Das Silent Pain. Ja, die
Copypasta, die habe ich mir auch schon in meinem Meme-Copypasta-Dokument gespeichert.
Ich habe hier ein extra Textdokument für Twitch Copypaste-Spam. Powerline, WLAN-Mech...
Okay, das ist nix für mich. Repeater. Warum haben die so viele Repeater? Die tun halt
so, als bräuchte man so viele Repeater. Repeater ist die schlechteste Lösung, um einen WLAN
zu verbreiten, wie es gibt. Besser, man macht ein paar Access Points nebeneinander, wenn
man die Möglichkeit hat, ein paar Kabel noch zu legen. Repeater ist nix, nix tolles. Also
nur die allerletzte Notlösung, wenn es gar nicht anders funktioniert. Wie hieß nochmal
der Scam-Repeater? Oh, ich hab Powerboost Plus oder irgendwie so hieß das Ding. Ja klar,
man kann einen Repeater verwenden, aber in der Regel Netzwerktechnik ist ein Repeater,
wenn man einfach nur seinen WLAN breiter aufspannen will, wenn man einfach nur eine größere Abdeckung
haben will, ist ein Repeater zwar die einfachste Lösung, allerdings von der Qualität her und
von der Geschwindigkeit her die schlechteste Lösung. Das heißt, wenn man beispielsweise
sagt, hey, ich möchte jetzt bei mir im Garten auch WLAN haben und man keine Möglichkeit
hat, irgendwie noch einen zweiten Access Point hinzubauen, der das abdeckt, dann macht man
ein Repeater. So, was haben wir denn sonst noch? Was ist das für ein hässliches Ding?
Mobiler WLAN Router. Wie denn Router? Ach, ok, da kann man quasi eine SIM-Karte reinmachen
oder so, das könnte ganz praktisch sein. Ok, was haben wir denn als nächstes? Noch mehr
Powerline-Gedöns brauchen wir nicht. Irgend so ein komisches Stealth-Bomber-Router wieder.
Also ehrlich Leute, bevor ich mir so ein Ding kaufe, dann hole ich mir lieber einen ordentlichen
Mikrotik-Router. Die haben ja auch welche mit WLAN jetzt mittlerweile, die ganz gut sind.
Oder hat man einfach das deutlich bessere Gerät. Brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht.
Access Point One Multimedia Allrounder WLAN Monster. Ist das Ding hier ernst? Heißt das
Ding wirklich WLAN Monster? Die meinen das ernst? WLAN Monster. Tolle Benahmung. Netgear
5-Port-Lan. Da muss ich nichts zu sagen. Also wenn man Ports braucht, kann man sich das
holen und gut isst. Also bei Switches im Bereich von 15-20€ einfach holen, wenn man es braucht,
da muss man sich keine großartigen Gedanken zu machen. Tun werden die alle. Schaut mal
mal was gucken. Der läuft ja mit 210 Zuschauern, das ist ja richtig, richtig nice heute. Also
80 mehr als sonst. Übrigens danke für die Follows. Wir haben hier den Colonel Sandfurz
und Samix HD. Und jetzt noch der Ben09. Sehr laut ist da. Ab und zu, ab und zu muss sehr
laut sein. Übrigens noch ein bisschen mehr ist sehr laut. Wir haben jetzt seit neuestem
auch einen Discord Server. Also wer Fragen hat, was Heimautomatisierung angeht oder irgendwelche
Programmiergeschichten, also das was wir eigentlich meistens hier im Stream machen,
kann natürlich gerne oder wer mit dem Sibaro gerne irgendwelche Anime-Webbildchen spammen
will, kann mal bei mir auf dem Discord vorbeigucken. Da gibt es auch einen Channel, der auf vielfachen
Wunsch, wo man seinen Steam-Account reinschreiben kann und ich schreibe seinen Comment rein.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das überhaupt ein Ding ist, bis mich da ein paar Leute gefragt
haben. Und ansonsten gibt es auch noch, wie gehabt, einen YouTube-Channel mit mittlerweile
260.000 Abos, wo es allerdings hauptsächlich ums Thema Gaming geht, wo ich ein bisschen
wenig mache in letzter Zeit. Und auf Twitter bin ich natürlich auch am Start, das heißt
wer sich meinen geistigen Wünschens auf Twitter anhören will, kann natürlich auch da gerne
vorbeigucken. Es ist alles im Profil drinne oder hier im Chat als Kommandos. Wir haben
ja alles mittlerweile. So, weiter. Der YouTube-Channel ist nur bait, genau. So. Wo sind wir stehengeblieben?
Netgear Switch. Okay. Switch müssen wir uns nicht erlangen, da gibt es ja wahrscheinlich
ja tausende. WLAN-Interne. WLAN-Karte, wann brauchen wir denn so ein Ding? Okay, wenn
man keinen Stick reinmachen will. Aber irgendwie sind ja jetzt keine Geräte dabei, wo ich
sagen würde, oh guck mal, leises Gerät und richtig günstig. Haben sie günstige Microtech-Dinger?
Guck mal mal. Haben sie günstige Microtech zum Prime vielleicht? Wahrscheinlich eher
nicht. Alter, warum wird gerade in der ganzen Musik gelabert? Nee, die Dinger sind natürlich
nicht reduziert und übelst teuer gerade. Hopp, lohnt sich nicht. Okay. Also so richtig
gut, hat mir bisher eigentlich nur die Preise für die Amazon eigenen Sachen gefallen und
das OnePlus 6 war ziemlich gut. Und die Festplatte, die war auch sehr nice. Okay, schauen wir
mal. Kategorie, oder habt ihr noch was gepostet? Zeig mal, hab ich vielleicht irgendwas übersehen?
Phillips-Wide-Ambient-Starterlampen. Ach, das sind solche Dinger. Smartphone. Schauen
wir mal. Zu Smartphones kann ich nichts sagen. Was ist denn ZTE überhaupt für einen Hersteller?
Hab ich noch nie was von gehört. Was war der Link für den Switch, der vorhin angesehen
wurde? Ähm, Moment. Da. Ja, NETGEAR GS108E. Von dem Hersteller hab ich nichts gehört,
null zu sagen. Ich hab von Smartphones keinen großartigen Plan. Ähm, und zu solchen Lampen.
Zu solchen Lampen kann ich eigentlich nur das sagen, was ich immer dazu sage. Man sollte
sich überlegen, was man will. Möchte man Lampen haben, die man quasi hauptsächlich
remote ein- und ausschalten kann? Oder ist es wirklich die RGB-Funktion, die man haben
will? Wenn man nämlich die Lampen einfach nur remote ein- und ausschalten will, oder
das ein großer Grund ist, dann würde ich das anders machen. Dann würde ich gucken,
dass ich mir einen WLAN-Relay einbaue in den Schalter. Weil die Sache ist die smarte Lampen
oder Smart-Lighting-Lightning? Smart-Lighting? Lightning? Wie heißt es denn richtig? Ich
brauch noch mein PillsTastyMan-Emote, wenn ich wieder Brain-Lags hab. Aber schlecht aufgelöst.
Leicht aufgelöstes Emote. Was ist das für ein beklagtes Emote? Ähm, wo waren wir gerade?
Genau. Also wenn es mir einfach darum geht, die Lampen ein- und ausschalten, dann würde
ich mir einen Relay an den Lichtschalter bauen. Weil Smart-Lighting ist nur so lange smart
wie der Lichtschalter an ist. Und wenn man nicht gerade alleine in der Wohnung ist, fällt
es einem oftmals schwer, dann nicht den Schalter zu verwenden. Was ja aber eigentlich auch ganz
natürlich ist, weil wenn du in den Raum reingehst und du willst dieses Licht aus, da willst
du nicht erst irgendwie in der App was machen oder auf ein Gerät rumdrücken, sondern willst
Lichtschalter hauen, angehen. Und deswegen würde ich empfehlen, eigentlich eher einen
Relay in den Schalter einzubauen, dass ich das schalten kann. Weil das macht die Lampe
auch smart und es funktioniert sowohl mit dem Schalter als auch mit dem Smartphone oder
mit der Heimautomatisierung. Wenn es der RGB-Teil ist, wenn es der RGB-Teil ist, dafür gibt
es ja extra Schalter. Ja, wozu brauche ich einen extra Schalter? Ich meine, ich habe
ja schon die Kabel durch die Wand liegen und die Fassung an der Decke hängen. Dann ist
ein WLAN-Relay das deutlich einfachere, was ich an den Lichtschalter anbauen kann. Und
dran musste so und so. Naja, zumindest wenn es der RGB-Teil ist von Lampen, die man haben
will, dann ist das bestimmt eine ganz gute Option und diese Philips-Dinger sind da auch
wohl, was ich so lese, eines der besten Sachen, die man sich holen kann. Ich persönlich habe
mit RGB-Lighting noch nicht so viel gemacht. Das Einzige, was ich habe, ich habe hier einen
LED-Strip, wo ich mir vorgenommen habe, dass ich für, genau die Shelly-Dinger sind sehr
gut, die habe ich auch schon öfters im Stream gezeigt. Also die Dinger hier sind gut, Shelly-1.
Die Dinger, mal auf, die sind wirklich nice, wenn man die Möglichkeit braucht, seine Lampen
ein- und auszuschalten zu können, Remote. Wohlgemerkt, wenn ihr sowas noch nicht gemacht
habt, lasst es euren Elektriker machen, in jedem Fall. Also es ist prinzipiell mit einem
passenden Bild dabei, ist nicht so, ist nicht großartig kompliziert. Aber ihr müsst auf
jeden Fall Strom ausmachen und wenn ihr das nicht gemacht habt und euch nicht wirklich
rantraut, lasst es euren Elektriker machen, das kostet nicht wahnsinnig viel und dann
ist es auf jeden Fall richtig gemacht. Und danach ist das Ding total einfach zu benutzen.
Das schöne an den Shelly-Dingern ist, wenn die einmal eingebaut sind, man kann sie verwenden
von jeder Automatisierungsplattform, von jedem Smartphone, von allen Geräten aus und das
auch ohne eine Cloud vom Hersteller. Ich sage es jedes Mal, wenn ich diese Dinger zeige,
die Domain ist das bescheuertste überhaupt. Das Hauptverkaufsargument dieses Produkts
ist, dass es keine Cloud benötigt und was haben sie als Domain genommen? Shelly.cloud.
Das ist halt wirklich nicht sonderlich clever, aber so heißt die Domain jetzt halt nun mal.
Und das ist als WLAN Relay richtig gut. Und dann kann man sich ja überlegen, wenn man
sowas hat, ob man nicht auch RGB-Beleuchtung reinmacht. Also ich werde mich mit dem Thema
RGB-Beleuchtung erst beschäftigen an Weihnachten. Ich habe mir nämlich letztens mal so eine
LED-Lichterkette gekauft, die man mit einem Mikro-Controller steuern kann. Da wollte
ich für Weihnachten ein bisschen Custom-Fensterbeleuchtung bauen. Das werden wir dann übrigens auch
im Stream bauen und bis dahin habe ich hoffentlich etwas gefunden, wie ich das auch per Kamera
zeigen kann. Ja. Aber ansonsten sollen diese Philips-Dinger echt ganz okay sein, was man
so liest. Ich habe persönlich keine Erfahrungen bisher mit. Was heißt Ballpartner? Ja, Flo.
Guck mal. Das heißt, du musst mir jetzt nicht jeden Tag ein Euro donaten, dass ich endlich
Partnerbewerbung mache. Ist das so eine Screenshot von Google? Ja, man weiß ja nicht. Vielleicht
ist es der ultimative Chebat von mir. Geh mal please durch diese Kategorie durch. Ich
wollte ja eigentlich noch gucken, was ich gebrauchen könnte. Und nicht nur irgendwelche
Links aus dem Q-Chat. Oh ja, unbedingt. Da haben wir drauf gewartet. Taugt da was?
Was ist denn das? 120 mm? Ja, 120 mm wahrscheinlich. Wenn man es braucht, warum nicht? Für mich,
ich brauche es nicht. Wobei ich ja mittlerweile eigentlich auch RGB-Fan bin. Allerdings
am liebsten an den Stellen, wo man es halt auch sieht. Also zum Beispiel das RGB in der
Tastatur finde ich mittlerweile nice. Das RGB von der Grafikkarte brauche ich nicht
unbedingt, weil da sieht man kaum. Ich finde immer mehr Links. Was ist das? Moment, das
sollten wir auch noch gucken. Angebote in Beauty. Klar, da bin ich genau der Richtige
für. Leute, ich habe euch wieder ein Produkt gefunden, das muss ich euch aber unbedingt
mal zeigen. Und zwar hier dieser Gillette 5 Broke Light. Ich zeige das ja nur, weil
ich euch so gerne habe und in meinem Chat das ich schon immer zeigen will. Und ich zeige
euch das nicht, weil ich irgendwie einen Vertrag mit denen habe, sondern weil ich mich wirklich
so freue, dass ich das gefunden habe. Der neue Gillette Fusion 5. Ich kann keinen Beauty
Sellout machen, das funktioniert nicht. Ich kriege das nicht auf die Reihe. Gillette Apli,
genau. Ihr zählt eigentlich noch. Das ist dann eher was für ein Apo Red hier. Digga,
Hugo Boss, Digga. Kritischer Hase. Oh Gott, ey, da kriege ich ja schon Fremdschämen,
wenn ich es nur ausspreche, ey. Okay, also was haben wir sonst noch so? Android Gamepad
Joystick. Es sieht aus wie ein Xbox-Controller, ohne ein Xbox-Controller zu sein. Nee, es
sieht aus wie ein... Es sieht eigentlich eher aus wie ein Playstation-Controller, der
ein Xbox-Controller sein will. Wozu braucht man sowas? Wer hat denn den Link gepostet?
Der Online-Ritter 747. Wozu genau braucht man sowas? Für Emulatoren. Wie, du hast für
Emulator auf dem Handy, oder was? Ich bin ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht auf die Idee
gekommen. Also für iOS gibt sowas wahrscheinlich eh nicht, weil Apple sagt, ne. Aber ich bin
noch gar nicht auf die Idee. Hab ich noch gar nicht angeguckt, was es für Emulatoren
für Android gibt. Müsste ich mir mal angucken. Der Vorteil hiervon ist, dass du so eine Handy-Halterung
dran hast. Warum nicht? Okay, was? Bewertung. Gaming-Controller. Hallo Gamer, liegt super
in der Hand. Ich find's immer besser, sich die schlechten Bewertungen anzukommen. Schlechteste
Bewertung. Ich wäre aber bei der ich je gekauft habe. Okay. Ja, dass es das auf Android gibt,
wundert mich nicht. Android ist ja auch POG, was sowas anbelangt. Ich weiß nicht. Oh,
das brauch ich nicht. Ich spiele im Endeffekt eh kaum Mobile-Zeug. Also die 20-30 Minuten
die ich im Zug sitze lohnt sich das nicht. Und ansonsten hab ich hier mein Desktop-Rechner,
wo ich spielen kann. Und im Zweifelsfall hätt ich auch noch ne Switch. Aber ich versteh
es, wenn man einen Emulator auf einem Android-Smartphone hat, ist das wahrscheinlich wirklich ne ganz
coole Geschichte. Die eins aus dem Titel kopiert, klar. Ihr kennt doch mein Tick, was einsen
kopieren anbelangt. Pewdie-Produkt. James Bond for Woman. Ja, genau. Oh, jetzt hab ich
das ja zugemacht, alles. Prime Day. Wir wollten ja noch Dings hier gucken. Prime Day Highlights.
Okay, wir gucken Highlights, alle Angebote. Highlights gucken wir uns an. SSDs. Das ist
ne Kategorie, die wollte ich mir eh nochmal angucken, was es für SSDs gibt. Weil neben
den Amazon-Produkten sind SSDs oftmals eine der wenigen Sachen, die sich wirklich lohnen
bei solchen Amazon-Aktionen zu kaufen. Also, was haben wir denn hier? Übrigens, was bei
diesen Western Digital externen Festplatten oftmals ganz gut ist oder externen SSDs oder
sagen wir externe Datenträger, was bei denen ganz gut ist, bei manchen, da muss man sich
vorher schlau machen, also, da hab ich mich nochmal festgehalten, ich sag jetzt nicht,
bei dem da ist das so, sondern nur, dass es bei Western Digital generell öfters mal so
ist, dass die richtig günstig sind, dass es sich richtig lohnt bei denen, sich die externen
Geräte zu kaufen und dann die interne Platte auszubauen da drinnen. Es gab letztens mal
wieder irgendwas, hab ich gelesen auf, ich glaub auf dem Self-Hosted-Reddit war das,
ne, Datahorder-Reddit war das, da hat einer einen Guide geschrieben, welche aktuellen
externen Geräte, also externe Laufwerke, man sich günstiger kaufen kann als das interne
Laufwerk, was drinnen ist. Also sprich, man kann sich, wenn man das Richtige kauft, die
interne Platte ausbauen und dafür verwenden, anstatt diesen komischen Dings da zu verwenden.
Wo man sich eigentlich erstmal denkt, total bescheuert, ne, warum ist die interne Platte
teurer als in der kompletten externen Box, aber anscheinend kommt das vor. Okay, vier
Terabyte ist mir alles viel zu klein, unter sechs Terabyte kaufe ich nichts mehr. Jetzt
kein Mixkapper, sondern ernsthaft, unter sechs Terabyte kaufe ich nichts mehr, eigentlich
unter acht nicht. Ich mach das immer so, also was ich mir im Kopf immer so überlege ist,
gibt es schon SSDs für normal Konsumer zu kaufen, die so groß sind, wie die Platte,
die man da vor sich hat. Wenn es das gibt, ab diesem Zeitpunkt kaufe ich nichts mehr,
was Platten angeht. Hat man das jetzt verstanden? Also es gibt jetzt mittlerweile halbwegs erschwinglich,
gibt es ja schon mittlerweile vier Terabyte SSDs und seit es das gibt, kaufe ich eben
keine vier Terabyte Platten mehr. Ich prime day. Das heißt, unter sechs Terabyte, eigentlich
unter acht Terabyte Platten, Platten kaufe ich nichts mehr. Ich meine, man kann es über
halbwegs erschwinglich streiten, allerdings, es ist auf jeden Fall nicht im vierstelligen
Bereich. Und ich handhab es am liebsten so, wenn es eine SSD in der Größe gibt, kaufe
ich keine Platte mehr und dann am liebsten mal zwei, ab dann kaufe ich wieder eine Platte.
Das heißt eigentlich acht Terabyte. Travel, warum hast du das gepostet? Kommt das jetzt
nicht noch hier gleich drinnen? Das könnte so eine zum Ausbauen sein tatsächlich. Okay,
blablabla, das ist die doch hier. Das sind die glaube ich zum Ausbauen. Das sind die
glaube ich zum Ausbauen. Gucken wir mal kurz. Ah, haben die da ein Bild zum Ausbauen? Genau,
ich bekomme mehr heute, blablabla. Ja, der Bounce ist aus. In der Amazon Rezession, okay.
Ich sehe jetzt noch nichts, aber kommt wahrscheinlich noch. Ah, Bildergalerie, besser. Ich sehe
hier keinen, der die Platte ausgebaut hat. Seht ihr das irgendwo? Bait, hier ist keiner,
der die Platte ausgebaut hat. Der Eiskäuter, she baited. Aber ich glaube auch, dass das
die Dinger sind, diese. Also das sind so Sachen, wo man halt immer schauen muss im Vorfeld,
ob das möglich ist, aber dann lohnt sich das. Weil lustigerweise die interne Platte, wenn
man die haben will, mehr kostet als eben das hier im Angebot gekauft und dann die Platte
ausgebaut. Sorry, was sie geht, siehste? Schreckt. Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht weiter
im, oh doch. Ich muss mal gucken, was kosten NVMe? Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten? Terabyte,
halbes Terabyte, Terabyte. Was kosten denn heute 2 TB NVMe? 2 Terabyte interne Platte.
Alter, ist das teuer. Ist das teuer. Okay, 450 kriegt man die normalerweise. Das ist teuer.
Das ist echt teuer. Das seh ich noch nicht so. Ich hab mir jetzt eine Terabyte, die liegt
hier irgendwo. Wo hab ich sie liegen? Hier. Terabyte NVMe SSD bestellt. Da ist sie. 970
EVO NVMe M2 SSD. Weil aktuell hab ich halt nur ne, aktuell hab ich halt nur ne halbes
1,5 TB drinnen. Ich hab aber noch ne 6 TB Festplatte dran, die ist hier auf dem Streaming
Account plus nicht gemountet. Also ich hab genug Speicher. Und im anderen Rechner hab
ich auch noch ne 2 TB SSD, die ich damals bescheuerterweise gekauft hab, als sie neu
war, für viel zu viel Geld. Und jetzt kosten die den Apple und ein Ei. Und ich werd's
so machen. Ich werd beide anschließen. Achja. Ich werd beide anschließen. Also das Mainboard
hat 3 M2 Slots. Und in dem einen ist halt aktuell die 500G SSD drinnen. Und da mach
ich jetzt die TB SSD noch dabei. Und dann hab ich 1,5 TB SSD. Und wenn man eins definitiv
nie genug haben kann, dann sind's SSDs. Oder wie seht ihr das? SSD beste. Also SSDs kann
man nie genug haben. Für nen 3600 Ryzen ERB450 oder X370 Board. Ich habe keinen flassen
Schimmer. Wir haben letztens geschaut, ob man nicht theoretisch nen Streaming Rechner
zusammenbasteln könnte. Und da haben wir uns nen X470 Board rausgesucht. Glaube ich war
das für 120€. Was gepasst hätte. Aber ich hab die Teile noch nicht bestellt. Und außerdem
ich baue mir auch keinen neuen Rechner. Sondern ich upgrade quasi den bestehenden nur. Da
kommt Mainboard raus. RAM und CPU kommt rein. Der Streaming Rechner wohlgemerkt nicht, der
Spiele Rechner. Der Spiele Rechner bleibt so wie der ist. Der Ritchie ist am Start. Das
ist nicht, dass man SSDs nicht komplett füllen soll, da man sonst Lebensdauer und Leistungsverlust
hat. Zumindest wurde mir das in einer Vorlesung so beigebracht. Ja das ist so der Unterschied
zwischen Theorie und Wirklichkeit. Du kannst ja ne SSD gar nicht komplett füllen. Weil
die SSDs haben ja standardmäßig schon nen Bereich, da kannst du gar nicht drauf schreiben.
Also die haben ja schon Reserve eingebaut. Und du kannst ja nicht am Controller vorbei
auf die SSDs schreiben. So und das nächste ist, dass man eine SSD eigentlich nicht kaputt
schreiben kann. Das hatte man am Anfang. Hatten die Leute so ein bisschen Schiss, dass
sie ihre SSDs kaputt machen, als SSDs neu waren. Und ich geh mal davon aus, dass von
diesen Leuten bis heute keiner geschafft hat seine SSD kaputt zu schreiben. Meine erste
SSD war von Samsung ne 250 Gigabyte Evo, was auch immer das damals hieß. Die ist bis heute
in dem Streaming Rechner drinnen. Und wenn man sich das anguckt, es gibt ja dieses Samsung
SSD Magic Programm. Und wenn du das jetzt anguckst, ist die SSD Haltbarkeit irgendwie
noch bei 96%. Also richtig. Also man kriegt keine SSDs kaputt. Wenn du SSDs kaputt schreiben
willst, dann müsstest du es wirklich drauf anlegen. Da müsstest du wirklich den ganzen
Tag über, ähm, müsstest du zwei SSDs kaufen und den ganzen Tag über, ähm, terabyteweise
Videos von einer SSD zu anderen verschieben. Warum haben wir heute eigentlich so krass
viele Zuschauer? Wir haben 100 Zuschauer mehr als sonst. Ich meine, das ist super nice,
ja. Kann ich nochmal sehr laut starten an der Stelle. Also ich finde es schön, dass
so viele neue Leute dabei sind. Willkommen im Streamsor. Wenn euch das Ganze gefällt,
könnt ihr mir natürlich gerne ein Follow dalassen. Ein Sub geht noch nicht, vielleicht
bald. Auf YouTube bin ich auch am Start. Da gibt es allerdings hauptsächlich Gaming-Content.
Oder wer sich dafür interessiert, äh, meinen geistigen Dünnschiss sich auf Twitter angucken
zu wollen, kann das natürlich auch machen. Unser neuestem haben wir sogar einen Discord
am Start für, äh, Programmierfragen, technische Geschichte, Heimautomatisierung und Sachen,
die es hier halt sonst so im Stream geht. YouTube ist halt nur bait, da gibt es sonst
nichts mehr. Ey, ich meine, ich haupe auf YouTube immerhin, ja. Also das muss man auch
erst mal schaffen. Man muss es erst mal schaffen, auf YouTube 280.000 Abos zu kriegen. So. Und
dann muss man es auch schaffen, trotz 280.000 Abos einfach keine Videos mehr zu produzieren.
Easy. Und dann ist man so bescheuert wie ich. Guckt euch das mal an, das ist armselig, äh.
Zwei Monate her, sieben Monate her, acht Monate her, acht Monate, neun Monate, ein
Jahr her. Das heißt, ich hab's letztes Jahr geschafft sechs Videos zu machen und dieses
Jahr irgendwie drei, ach, keine Ahnung. Liegt aber einfach auf YouTube daran, zeigt man
deine Abobverluste, so ungefähr, es schwankt, es schwankt so zwischen zehn und und 25 oder
zehn und 35 am Tag, so irgendwie in dem Dreh. Und ich find's halt immer blöd, man sieht's,
man sieht's immer, jedes Mal, ne, wenn ich anfange wieder Videos hochzuladen und das
ne Weile durchhalte, seh ich auch jedes Mal in den Analytics, wie es wieder besser wird,
ja. Und es motiviert mich dann wieder, dann mach ich ein bisschen weiter, dann seh ich,
dass es noch besser wird und irgendwann hab ich da wieder so meine Phase, wo ich sage,
ah, da kann man mal Videos machen. Ganz schlimm, ich wüsste das eigentlich einfach mal durchhalten.
Sackt. Ich seh das jedes Mal in Analytics und auf Social Play, siehst du das auch jedes
Mal, wenn ich wieder anfange Videos zu machen, geht's immer hoch. Ja. Aber, ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, Twitch Streams macht mir jetzt in letzter Zeit mehr Bock. Ich vermisse die
guten, allen Battlefield 3 und Bad Company Zeiten. Ich auch. Ich hoffe ja drauf, dass
Bad Company 3 gut wird und dass es mal wieder Spiele gibt, die ich spielen will. Das wär
super nice so, ja. Ok, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? SSDs haben wir geguckt. Warte mal,
was gab's an NVMe SSDs? Halbes Terabyte-dings, nee nix, nur. Gibt's da vielleicht die SSDs,
die ich mir bestellt hab? Nee. Nur irgendwelche, ich will nicht sagen No Name, aber nur irgendwelche,
nicht Samsung auf jeden Fall. Da hätt ich bestimmt noch am Morgen gucken müssen, da
gab's mehr. Ist Bad Company 3 konfirmed? Nee. Nur geleakt. Samsung gab's auch, ja, aber
keine Samsung NVMe, oder? SanDisk. Tencent. Also nicht die Dinger, die ich mir geholt
hab. Nicht die Dinger, die ich mir geholt hab. Habe. Ich kann nicht mal richtig reden.
Ach doch, die ist nur schon weg. Das bringt's mir ans Allerwer. Hätt ich doch gesagt,
hätt ich wahrscheinlich heute Morgen gucken müssen. Was ist der beste Low Budget SSD
Hersteller? Also was ich mir jetzt für die ganzen Kisten geholt hab hier, wer im Stream
dabei ist öfters, der wird's ja wissen, ich bin ja gerade dabei, meinen Technikraum
bisschen umzubauen. So sieht er jetzt aktuell aus. Steht ein bisschen mehr noch. Crap drum
herum mittlerweile. Ich will diese 4HE-Kiste abschaffen und will ich ablösen durch zwei
kleine stromsparende Kisten. Und für die hab ich mir jetzt gekauft, sag ich dir, hab
ich auch bei der letzten Prime-Geschichte gekauft und zwar Crucial MX 500 hab ich mir
einfach gekauft. Gibt sie vielleicht heute? Ist das ein Prime-Day-Angebot? Hier, ne?
Also die find ich budgetmäßig ganz, ganz okay, die Dinger hier. Und wahrscheinlich
ist das wie der übliche Amazon-Preis-Jubate, wahrscheinlich kriegst du die woanders sogar
noch künstiger. Ja genau, die ersten Leute schreiben ja schon, hab ich mir für 50 Euro
gekauft. Die find ich nicht schlecht. Die hab ich jetzt mal in zwei kleinen stromsparenden
Kisten verpasst und die laufen damit auch wunderbar. Okay, also jetzt machen wir mal
die ganzen Krempel hier wieder zu Amazon und geh noch mal auf die Prime-Angebote und
zwar, was wollt ich gucken, Computer und vor allem wollt ich mal schauen, was die für
Elektronikzeug heute noch am Start haben und was es für Amazon-Basics Sachen gibt. Amazon-Basics
krieg ich auch immer ganz gerne, weil die Dinger sind qualitativ ausreichend und immer
relativ günstig. Gucken, was es alles Amazon-Basics gibt. Machen wir hier alle Kategorien,
da kann man bestimmt einstellen. Basics. Stop, kann man nicht. Ganz schön unübersichtlich.
Machen wir hier Elektronik und Foto. Und irgendjemand wollte vorhin noch Monitore gucken.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dazu viel sagen kann. Monitore, das einzige, was ich bei Monitoren
gucken würde, wenn ich mir neu kaufe, mindestens 144 Hertz, am besten gleich, wenn es neu ist,
240 für Gaming und der Rest. Easy. Ist das jetzt Elektronik? Ah, das ist Computer und
Software. Elektronik und Foto ist das hier, okay. Asus PG279, ist das der mit dem Lüfter?
Das ist der mit dem Lüfter, oder? Ja, das ist glaube ich der mit dem Lüfter. Asus
hat es nämlich geschafft, ein Monitor zu bauen, der einen Lüfter braucht. Dann ist
es nicht der, okay. Aber ich habe es gesehen, Amazon hat der super High-End Gaming Monitor
von Asus, oder Asus, wie es ja offiziell heißt, so sagen sie zumindest selbst, braucht einen
Lüfter, weil er sonst nicht kalt genug bleibt. War das nicht den OLED? Ja, kann sein. Ja,
Fernseher hat einen Lüfter, echt? Asus, Asus mögen sie nicht, haben sie mir gesagt. Asus
die Aussprache mögen sie nicht. Asus und Asus mögen sie, aber Asus mögen sie nicht.
Einfach ein Follow Gary, und wen haben wir noch? Doktor Ben 09 hatten wir schon. Gibt
es hier irgendwie eine schöne Übersicht über die Kategorien, oder sind das hier alle Kategorien?
Ach nee, hier. Master of Duck, auch am Start. Wer noch nicht gefollowed ist und dem das
Stream gefällt, jetzt ist die Zeit zum Follow drücken. Könnt ihr sagen, ihr habt gefollowed,
bevor der Subbutton da ist? Falls es den Subbutton gibt. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, es sei
denn, die gucken sich wirklich meinen Clip an, den ich vorhin gezeigt habe, dann nicht.
Smart Home, oh ja, da müssen wir mal gucken, was es da gibt, das war es für mich. Wirosoft,
scannen wir da mal schnell, das ist so viel, da kann sich doch keiner alles angucken. Amazon
Basics, da gibt es doch garantiert eine eigene Kategorie dazu. Amazon Basics, 15-teiliges
Kochgeschirr, anti-Haft-beschichtet. Jawoll. Meint ihr, Elektronik und Fotos sind Reinigungszüge?
Ach ja klar, für die Kamera. Ok, Batterien braucht kein Mensch. USB-Kabel habe ich ja
nun wirklich mittlerweile genug. Ich habe jetzt heute mal geguckt, DHL, Sendeverfolgung,
meine USB-Kabel sind unterwegs. Meine 200 USB-Kabel. Nee, 50 USB-Kabel sind es nur.
50 USB-Kabel, Mikro-USB, inklusive Adapter auf USB-C. Bei AliExpress für, ich glaube,
75 Euro, was im Endeffekt, nee, 100 Stück, 75 Euro, 50 Stück waren glaube ich 48 Euro.
Also sprich, für weniger als einen Euro das USB-Kabel, einen Meter USB-Kabel, Mikro-USB-Kabel,
einen Meter, inklusive einen Adapter vorne dran auf USB-C. Klar waren die 200 Kabel gebated,
der Support-Typ von AliExpress hat plus Mist geschrieben. Ich habe ja auch nur 50 bestellt.
Der Typ hat einfach nur 200 reingepastet, als wahrscheinlich hat er vorher mit irgendeinem
Typ geschrieben, der 200 USB-Kabel bestellt hat. Wie lange ein Kabel wohl halten wird,
wahrscheinlich wird die meisten der Kabel beim ersten Mal anschalten schon verrecken.
Nee, ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn man die einfach nur verwendet, um irgendwie einen
Mikro-Controller, einen Raspberry mit Strom zu versorgen, werden die Kabel ganz normal
halten. Was man mit den Kabel wahrscheinlich nicht machen darf, ist sie öfters an- und
abstecken. Amazon Basics Gaming Mousepad. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass sie sowas haben
mittlerweile. 48 Batterien für 10,99 Euro. Wie viele Mikroampere-Stunden? Was ist denn
da so drinnen immer? 600? Was ist denn da so drinnen? Ich meine 48 Stück für 11 Euro.
Ach, das ist gar kein Akku, stimmt. Ja, ist gut. Ja, hier ist ja der Chat wieder. Der Chat,
gleich am Start, sagst du einmal, war es falsch, jetzt kommst du, Max, nein, das gibt es an
der Stelle nicht. Monka Smoke. Bei AliExpress-Akkus ist Monka Smoke angesagt. Was hat denn Amazon
Basics Messerblock denn in Elektronik und Fotos zu suchen? Nee, irgendwie gibt es da nichts
wie Scheiß. Okay Leute, welche Kategorie wollen wir uns jetzt angucken? Ich bin irgendwie
ein bisschen unschlüssig. Ich bin so erschlagen irgendwie von 30.000 Kategorien und Games.
Oh, nee. Da gibt es eh nichts, was mir gefällt. Der Online-Ritter ist aber aktiv hier heute.
Welche der runter gesetzten Monitore kannst du empfehlen? Schauen wir mal. Nicht, dass
ich mich großartig auskennen würde aktuell, was Monitore und generell Desktop-PCs angeht.
Liegt einfach daran, ich beschäftige mich immer damit, wenn es akut ist, wenn ich was
brauche. Hast du schon das Angebot zum LG UC 990 gesehen? Nee. Der da? Ich weiß nicht,
ob der im Angebot ist. Moment, das ist gar kein Fernseher. Das ist ein 38 Zoll für Grafik-Design-Zeugs-Curved.
Vielleicht schon ausverkauft. Ja, kann sein. Aber man kann hier oben doch nach Primeday
suchen. Ist natürlich schon ausverkauft. Übrigens, wer sowas noch nicht hat, Leute,
das ist sehr praktisch. So ein höhenverstellbarer Schreibtischgestell. Das ist wirklich sehr,
sehr praktisch. Kann man sich zwischendurch mal hinstellen, man kann die Höhe ein bisschen
verstellen, je nachdem, wie man gerade sitzt, ist praktisch. Sitzt du eigentlich auf einem
Gaming-Stuhl? Nein, nicht mehr. Ich hatte da vorne einen DX Racer, allerdings hat es
dann irgendwann mal die Armlehne abgebrochen vom DX Racer. Einfach beim Aufstehen. Ich
meine, ich bin nicht der Leichteste. Ich bin jetzt allerdings bestimmt auch nicht der fetteste
der auf seinem DX Racer sitzt. Das heißt, beim Aufstehen sollte definitiv nicht die
Armlehne abbrechen. Und jetzt habe ich mir einen ganz normalen Office-Stuhl gekauft danach
und der ist viel besser als der DX Racer, Leute. Der ist so viel angenehmer, hochwertiger
verarbeitet, hat auch ein bisschen mehr gekostet, aber ist einfach viel angenehmer auf dem zu
sitzen als auf einem Gaming-Stuhl. 150kg Grenze überschnitzen. Sick. Ja. Weder die 150kg Grenze
noch die 100kg Grenze. Ich hatte die 100kg Grenze mal, allerdings, ich habe es ja in letzter
Zeit schon auf Twitter öfters mal geschrieben. Ich habe jetzt fast, na 10kg sind es noch nicht
ganz, innerhalb der letzten, so 3 Monate, so 8kg abgenommen. Einfach, und jetzt kommt
es, super krasser Ablebendrick, einfach weniger gegessen. Easy. Einfach nichts sonst. Einfach
weniger gegessen. Richtig Big Brain. Klingt nicht machbar. Doch, einfach weniger essen.
Ich habe vorher mittags, also wir haben eine Kantine bei uns, mittags immer massig gefressen.
Ich habe teilweise auf dem Rückweg, ich laufe immer an einer Eisdiele vorbei, habe ich
mir noch Eis geholt. Wenn ich dann heimgekommen bin, bin ich meistens noch ein bisschen draußen
rumgelaufen, einfach weil man den ganzen Tag auf der Arbeit gesessen hat. Da ist nochmal
so eine Oma mit einer Eisdiele, da habe ich mir oftmals ein Eis geholt. Ich habe einfach
viel, viel zu viel gefuttert. Und von diesen 8kg ist wahrscheinlich ein Drittel, das was
einfach, das habe ich nicht abgenommen, das ist wahrscheinlich einfach was weniger im
Umlauf drinne ist. Und was ich jetzt auch viel mehr mache, ist Zeug trinken. Ich sehe
es noch 4 Monate. Aber es ist nicht lang, es ist nicht Anfang des Jahres. Ich hab es
letztens auf Twitter gepostet, da war es ziemlich aktuell. Jetzt gehen die beiden Eisdiele pleite.
Ja, man kann nicht alle Leute glücklich machen. Hast du noch Kontakt zum Friseur? Klar. Das
liegt aber an, den Friseur kannte ich vor YouTube und vor dem ganzen Online-Seug und
mit dem habe ich immer noch Kontakt. Genau. Server-Admin erfindet unglaubliche Abnehmendiet.
Mediziner hassen ihn. Mediziner hassen diesen, diesen, ja, irgendwas. Klickt bei Titel.
Aber Server-Admin ist zu, ich habe jetzt schon eine Job-Bezeichnung gesucht, die die Leute
kennen. Mit DevOps-Engineer muss ich da nicht anfangen. Aber Server-Admin ist auch noch
zu technisch für die. Wie könnte man so eine schöne Clickbait-Titel machen? Computer-Freak
erfindet unglaublichen Abnehmendrick. Ärzte hassen ihn dafür. Nein, nicht Informatiker,
Computer-Freak. Das ist, das ist, das ist der richtige, die Titel müssen immer so sein.
Computer-Nerd, genau, Computer-Nerd erfindet unglaublichen Abnehmendrick. Ärzte hassen
ihn. Computer-Nerd erfindet krassen Abnehmendrick. Mediziner hassen diesen, ja, irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie sowas. Das muss ich als nächstes Mal als Stream-Titel machen. Okay, was, was
haben sie denn hier beim Thema Smart Home? Das ist jetzt ja die passende Kategorie für
mich. Staubsauger-Roboter. Wie sieht's aus? Gibt's wieder einen S50? Ich bräuchte ja
noch einen zweiten, immer noch. Nö, gibt's nicht. Was sagt ein Guides-Halt eigentlich
dazu? Ich muss mein Sellout, ich muss echt mein Sellout noch verbessern. Immer wenn ich
Sellout, immer wenn ich Follower, also Follow Sellout mache, Follower, keiner. Ich kann
das einfach nicht überzeugend genug. Ich will keinen S5, ich will einen S50.
Oh, viel zu teuer. 280 ist okay. Viel zu teuer, dann trag ich lieber die Treppe hoch und
runter. Nee, jetzt hab ich's hier zugemacht. Wo ist Smart Home? Da. Also ich hab hier aktuell
hab ich zwei Staubsauger-Roboters. Ich hab einmal einen Xiaomi S50. Das Ding ist ziemlich
gut, das hat so ein Laser-Ding drauf, was den Raum scannt. Der ist halt ziemlich schnell,
hat nen Teppich-Reinigungsmodus und kann theoretisch auch den Boden wischen, wenn man Wasser rein
macht, verwende ich aber nicht. Der ist wirklich gut, der ist allerdings ein ticken zu hoch
und für unter den Schränken, unterm Bett hab ich noch einen Eufy E10 oder sowas. Das
Ding, was keine Cloud braucht. Xiaomi, die Dinger heißen so. Xiaomi. Das heißt ja nicht
Xiaomi. Was heißt ja nicht Xiaomi oder so. Ich glaub man spricht das so aus. Also ich
habe vor jeglicher Art Roboter zu viel Angst, dass ich mich mit dem Schlaf umbringe. Da
darfst du dir aber auch keine Katze oder so holen, da weiß man auch nicht so genau. Und
vor ein paar Jahren fand ich Staubsauger-Roboter übelst overrated Bullshit. Bis ich mir irgendwann
mal gedacht hab, lass doch mal einen holen, da gab es gerade einen im Angebot. Und seit
ich mir das Ding geholt hab, bin ich Fan davon. Ganz tolles Zeug, wirklich sehr nice. Immer
unter der Voraussetzung, sie brauchen keine Cloud und sie lassen sich ordentlich steuern.
Die Eufy-Kiste kann ich ganz einfach mit einem Infrarotmodul von einem Raspberry an- und
ausschalten. Der kann halt sonst gar nichts. Der kann einfach nur blöd geradeaus fallen
bis er gegen die Wand fährt, dann dreht er um. Und den Roborock S50, den hab ich geflasht.
Wir sind mittlerweile schon so weit, im Jahr 2019 flasht man seinen Staubsauger. Den hab
ich geflasht hiermit. Irgendwie so hieß das Ding. Das da. Damit hab ich den Staubsauger
geflasht. Da hat man den Webinterface. Ich glaub ich hab's mal auf Twitter gepostet.
Da! Da ist ein Bild vom Tablet, was bei mir im Flur hängt. So sieht das Webinterface
aus. Also das ist generell mein Home Assistant Webinterface. Und ein Tab davon ist halt für
den Staubsauger Roboter. Und man sieht ja, das ist das gleiche Webinterface wie da.
Halt bloß, dass man hier meinen Erdgeschoss sieht und da halt dem tut sein Erdgeschoss.
Und was erstaunlich ähnlich aussieht irgendwie. Zumindest das Webinterface vom, das ist ein
iFrame, ja. Das Webinterface vom Staubsauger ist wirklich praktisch. Du kannst dir, also
erst mal scannt das Ding das automatisch das Layout vom Haus. Das hat so ein Laser obendrauf.
Ah, hier siehst du mal. Da ist ein Laser drin. Da dreht sich. Wie viel Quadratmeter? Gute
Frage. Nächste Frage. Keine Ahnung. Hab das vom Opa, oder? Wir haben das vom Opa geerbt?
Also ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich weiß es nicht. Ähm, ungefähr. Boah, ey. Keine Ahnung. Ich
würd's dir sagen, ich weiß nicht. Ist zumindest geräumig genug für zwei Personen. Ähm, so
und, wo war ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Genau. Das Webinterface läuft direkt auf dem Staubsauger
Roboter. Also sprich, ähm, was der Euphi ist in Prime Days drinne, schick mir mal den
LinkxxFatal. Da kann ich dir sagen ob das meiner ist. Den Aufzug vom Opa gibt's nicht
mehr. Zumindest, worauf ich raus will ist, ähm, das Ding scannt komplett die Stockwerke
ein. Hat man so ne Map. Und wenn man so ne Map hat, kann man im Webinterface ähm, Regionen,
Regionen und Spots definieren. Wo man dann sagen kann, hey, wobei, ich zeig's euch,
soll ich's euch mal zeigen? Ich hab's zwar im Stream schon mal gezeigt, aber ich kann's
noch mal zeigen. Ich muss mal erst mal gucken, was das Ding für ne IP hat. Ich muss mal kurz
in meine History gucken, was das Ding für ne IP hat. Weil ansonsten komm ich nur über
mein Heimautomatisierungs-Dashboard drauf und das will ich euch nicht zeigen. Moment,
ich muss mal kurz suchen, wo ich den Mist hab. Ich hab's gleich. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Was? Ähm, ich muss mal auf meinen Router draufkocken. IP, DACP-Server. Was ist das
leases robo ach hier 107 ja genau jetzt kann ich es euch zeichnen ja so sieht das aus
tablet freundlich ja ist tablet freundlich also du kannst hier drüber swipen über das
gui die map spackt gerade ein bisschen rum kanns drüber swipen es sind verschiedene
verschiedene spots definiert also ich kann zum beispiel sagen unter der treppe sauber machen
wohnzimmer sauber machen flur schlafzimmer kirche bad bad oben bad oben blablabla blub und
dann fährt er dahin ja hier kann man die zonen definieren hier sieht man normalerweise die map
die hier irgendwie gerade ein bisschen rumspackt und man kann das ding manuell manuell steuern das
macht natürlich besonders viel spaß vom tablet aus machen sich nämlich kann man sich mit dem
tablet quasi in flur stellen und wie mit so einem ferngesteuerten auto sein staubsauger robotter
rum rum fahren lassen das kann man doch auch alles mit der shiomi app machen richtig allerdings
finde ich manche sachen nicht so gut wie zum beispiel maps back-up maps wieder herstellen
und das problem ist das geht nur über die china cloud ist die china cloud nicht da geht
ein staubsauger robotter nicht und ich weiß auch nicht ob du deinen grundriss unbedingt in der china
cloud speichern willst kann jeder machen wie er will hier kann man auch einstellen wie er den
teppich reinigt dass er extra extra viel sagt wenn der teppich am start ist wenn der teppich
feststellt ja und man kann hier auch einstellen wie er reinigen soll mit wenn man wasser in den
tank gefüllt hat ja und hier hier kann man einstellen was der super power huge power
so sieht das bei mir aus jetzt habt ihr auch mal einen staubsauger mit web interface gesehen
ist die cloud extern oder auf allem die cloud ist cloud bedingt extern und zwar in china
deswegen habe ich das ding ja auch geflasht deswegen habe ich das ding ja auch geflasht
und betreibt es jetzt lokal und das web interface ist lokal auf dem staubsauger drauf
hat er also links um auf wie geschickt
prime angebot ja das ist glaube ich meiner das ist der ohne cloud oder
ja der ist gut das ist das ist ein super einsteiger staubsauger robot der preis
ist auch ganz okay ich gucke mal kurz was ich für meinen bezahlt habe mal kurz gucke
aber ich das gleiche mal ob das ein ordentlicher preis ist mein preis damals war ziemlich gut
deswegen ja system einer hat sogar 150 noch gekostet also wenn man keinen sonderlich intelligenten
staubsauger robot haben will ist das hier wirklich gut also mit keinem sonderlich intelligent
manche keinen der räume scannen kann keinen den man ordentlich irgendwie über smartphone
steuern kann wer einfach nur den staubsauger robot haben will der funktioniert und sauber
macht ohne großartige großartigen schnick schnack sind die auf ist das auf jeden wirklich
gut moment mal das ist doch der falsche ich habe nur ich habe nun auf 11 kann das sein
dass das der doch ist mit ab nie das ist wichtig weil die haben auch welche die mit ab funktionieren
oder nur mit ab funktionieren dann hast du wieder das china ab problem also ich würde
noch mal nachgucken ob das der ist der wirklich auch offline funktioniert nur mit fernbedienung
weil die fernbedienung ist auch infrarot die könnt ihr auch total einfach mit einem raspberry
nachmachen wenigstens ich glaube wenn alles funktioniert lohnt sich das nicht ne homo
system hat eine schönere web interface iopro gab schon auch seine vorteile also ich habe
den 11 nicht den 11 s und das ist ein wirklich wird den preis ist das ein super staubsauger
robotter und das schöne an dem ist der ist relativ relativ klein also der passt wie man
es hier sieht auch ohne problemen und dann sofort runter bei mir unter das bett unter
den schrank unter die schränke unten wusstest du dass overwatch die ehe die auf dritter
voll und ne wusste ich nicht aber wahrscheinlich kommt es noch aus zeiten wo ich mich vergeblich
mal als semi amateur overwatch pro möchte gern pro versucht habe und wahrscheinlich
auch von youtube ja gehe ich mal von aus war einer ich war damals in deutschland einer
der ersten der overwatch beta zugang hatte in deutschland es war war pock und damals
habe ich noch richtig große richtig große hoffnung für das game gehabt ja also lohnt
sich das ding wenn staubsauger robotter sucht und preisleistungsmäßig ein sucht der einfach
funktioniert ist sind diese ist dies hier der 11 s ist wirklich nicht verkehrt kann
man sich auf jeden fall gönnen was gibt es denn sonst noch hier smart home mäßiges
steckdosen das sind wahrscheinlich so steckdosen die ich mir nie im leben kaufen würde wie
viele steckdosen gibt es dann da bitte schön ok das wird uns nicht alles angucken ist wahrscheinlich
nix dabei was ich mir kaufen würde fernsee moment fernsee für 89 euro was sollen das
sein die bete das gibt überhaupt kein für 89 euro doch unten oh habe ich sie verguckt
ja die bet doch da tatsächlich die beten hat mich gebadet mehr aldi aldi medium ne wobei
medium ist ja nicht unbedingt aldi aber aldi hat immer medium was zum teufel sind das für
ant ok sie haben wenigstens noch ein hdmi nebendran 15,6 zoll
der hier also so machst du da definitiv nicht weil so erkennst du da drauf nix aber sie
vermarkten das auch schon für im fernsee im auto oder so aber die anschlüsse sind
wirklich antik ein vga anschluss den skat anschluss leute ernsthaft was was wann habt
ihr zuletzt den skat anschluss nicht ob nicht vielleicht gesehen wann habt ihr zuletzt
den skat an den kabel den skat kabel in der hand gehabt also bei mir ist das locker zehn
jahre her 2012 ja also lang ein klinke anschluss einen antennen anschluss noch einen antennen
anschluss und noch einen koax spdv ok und neben haben wir einen sagenhaft einen hdmi
geiles zeug eher nicht so das was ich mir kaufen würde aber wo soll ich ohne skat anschluss
meinen vrs player anschließen du kaufst dir ne capture card und schließt deinen vrs player
über die capture card an dann machst du dein capture programm auf und screen captures das
an dein smart tv per chromecast was sagst du dazu
eine capture card mit skat ne du brauchst ja keine capture card mit skat das reicht ja
wenn du den skat wenn du den skat anschluss hast mit einem s-video ausgang skat auf s-video
kostet 2,50 euro
primeley hat mein geldbeutel erst mal ein saugerroboter und 10 terabyte gegönnt finde
ich finde ich finde ich lustig weil eines der wenigen sachen die wir bisher gefunden
haben bar prime war eine 10 terabyte platte und einen richtig guten preis für einen staubsaugeroboter
oder hast du das aus dem stream hier
osram smarte beleuchtung trifft im prinzip auch alles das zu was ich vorher zu smarten
klübieren gesagt habe würde ich mir so nicht holen es sei denn ich bin wirklich ganz scharf
auf diese rgb komponente und will nicht einfach nur an und ausschalten
ach max er hat das aus dem stream wo soll ich das wissen es gibt ja durchaus durchaus
leute die was kaufen bei amazon und im stream danach erst nachher join wiste von wegen
den ihr heute morgen schon bestellt die steckdosen sind nice na ich weiß nicht ok für acht
euro kann man da nicht viel verkehrt machen und ich denke mal dass man die auch mittlerweile
über alle möglichen automatisierungssysteme steuern kann und nicht nur die offizielle
app kann man die flaschen wahrscheinlich kann man die nicht flaschen oder ich denke mal
dass man sie nicht flaschen kann aber man wird sie wahrscheinlich anderweitig ansteuern
können ja sich die alleine heißt noch nichts sie ist nicht wie sie offen dass jedes gerät
mit jedem funktioniert sie heißt erst mal nur es ist sie nicht dass das eine gerät
mit dem anderen sprechen kann sie leitet schon ja dann dann ist es was wo sie sich darauf
geeinigt haben bis zu 30 prozent stark reduzieren netzmeerkomponenten das ist das was wir vorhin
schon auf hatten kameras doorbell obbräunig habe dabei eine billy china camp dran die gehen
problemlos ja das ist auch gut ist nice also für acht euro kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt
machen was eine remote schaltbare steckdose anbelangt noch mehr staubsäure robot a frau
m fritz deck 210 was genau ist das eine telephone deckstation oder was ach nee das ist dieses
komische fritz smart home gedöns was über deckt funktioniert deckt in 2k 19 ein gibt
schlimmeres aber wirkt irgendwie nicht mehr so ganz zeitgemäß oh es gibt die uns gibt
unsere china steckdosen leiste leute das ist unsere china steckdosen leiste könnt ihr
euch noch dran erinnern das ist nicht exakt die das ist nicht exakt unsere china steckdosen
leiste aber ich könnte wetten da ist unter der haube der gleiche mist drinne wie in unserer
china steckdosen leiste ja weil wir haben ja weil heute zu viele neue leute dabei ist
erzähl ich das noch mal wir haben ja vor ein paar streams eine china steckdosen leiste
geflasht und das ging so was von dass ich mir gleich noch mehr bestellt habe und geflasht
die da haben wir bestellt ich kann mir wirklich diesen komischen hersteller merken die da
haben wir geflasht kogeek was bringt das flaschen du kannst die steckdosen leiste über ein
webinterface ein und ausschalten und nicht nur über die offizielle app also da sieht
man mal wir sind richtig 2019 heute wir haben geflashte staubsauger heute schon im stream
gehabt geflashte steckdosen im stream gehabt normale menschen flaschen den grill und max
und max flascht seine steckdosen leiste ja so ist es das bringt aber was man kann über
ein webinterface die die einzelnen steckdosen schalten und ich könnte mir vorstellen auch
bei der die es hier im angebot gibt wo ist er denn ich blick überhaupt nicht mehr durch
wir müssen mal gucken ob wir die flaschen kann ob der irgendjemand was von flaschen
geschrieben hat oder das motor wir müssen mal kurz gucken wir versuchen mal in erfahrung
zu bringen ob man den mist flaschen kann ich mein wer kennt ihr nicht der weltbekannte
hersteller aus tech und aus dann erbauen wir dich nicht anscheinend kann man die doch nicht
flaschen wobei ich könnte wetten wenn man das ding aufmacht und dass da auch ganz normalen
esp86 drin ist den man doch flaschen kann aber sieht es nicht so einfach aus die sache
zu flaschen zumindest die frage noch mal zu beantworten was man davon hat wenn man
eine steckdosen leiste flascht wohlgemerkt die haben wir geflascht das letzte mal nicht
die hier und wenn man sich überlegt 23 euro 99 zu 29 euro dann würde ich lieber zu der
greifen wo ich mir sicher bin dass man sie flaschen kann hast du schon über den höhenverstellbaren
schreibtisch gesprochen ja beste beste also ich habe ja auch einen am start ich habe
es ja auch so gemacht dass ich mir so ein unter so ein untergestell gekauft habe und
die tischplatte habe ich gleich habe ich quasi von vorher gelassen gestellt runter gemacht
angeschraubt und an die beine ab ist ist sehr angenehm unverstellbarer schreibtisch wirklich
sehr angenehm würde ich würde ich wieder kaufen du musst nur gucken dass der auch ein
paar kilo heben kann das ding weil die platte ist schwer die ganzen monitore drauf sind
schwer hast du die zwei boxen drauf ein paar geräte also ich sag mal so 50 kilo sollte
das ding schon heben können mindestens man draufsetzen kannst du dich dann nicht ja und
um das noch mal kurz zu erzählen warum warum die steckdosen leiste geflascht erstens natürlich
die original steckdosen leiste braucht man wieder eine china cloud und china cloud wisst
ihr ich bin ja ganz großer fan von china cloud weil china cloud kommt bei mir nicht
in die tüte und ich habe auch keinen bock dass ich das nur über eine smartphone app
steuern kann deswegen haben wir das ding geflasht das alles in web interface über das man jede
einzelne steckdose schalten kann oder auch sogar die usb allerdings die usb kann man
nur gemeinsam schalten und man kann das über alle mögliche anderen protokolle auch direkt
erst aus der heim automatisierung schalten ich habe es jetzt so gemacht ich habe eine
steckdosen leiste drüben im kabuff an meinem 3d drucker da ist der 3d drucker dran und
der raspberry mit der kamera und das macht jetzt einfach so jedes mal wenn ich es ist
noch nicht so eingerichtet wenn es eingerichtet wäre könnte ich euch zeigen jedes mal wenn
ich jetzt in octoprint reingehe könnte ich so machen dass er dann automatisch mein 3d
drucker startet was machst du mit dem 3d drucker zum beispiel gehäuse für iot devices ausdrucken
zum beispiel ich zeige euch mal was zeigen was ich ausgedruckt habe ich zeige euch mal
was ich will das jetzt nicht aufmachen ich weiß nicht ob das von mir ist ich habe mir
zum beispiel letztens ein gehäuse getrocknet
jetzt habe ich mal ein foto gemacht wie kriege ich das foto jetzt in stream am besten damit
das problem aber doch jedes mal oder dass ich meine photos immer nicht in stream kriege
vom handy da muss ich mir auch mal was überlegen nextcloud ja geht nicht gerade hier ich bin
noch hier ich bin noch hier von dem streaming rechner in 2 eingeloggt ich lade euch das
jetzt einfach mal schnell hoch dass eine gaming steckdose mit extra nitrile latenz ja zum
thema gaming steckdose da zeige ich dir klar was
aber jetzt erst noch mal zum thema was man so mit dem 3d drucker macht
die seite ist mega langsam
foto library
so also was man so mit dem 3d drucker machen kann
ich mache wie gesagt man kann sich natürlich einfach sachen irgendwie models besorgen und
unsinnige sachen drucken wie flexi dinosaurier oder sowas
allerdings hat man davon ja nicht sonderlich viel
ich habe ich drucke hauptsächlich gehäuse für irgendwelche iot geschichten aus zum
beispiel hierfür mein laura gateway und zwar im im im im im durr alles schreiben
ach nee das war was anderes ähm wollten nur mal gucken ähm m n a lma 0 das alter nicht
schon wieder ist es ein o kein null nee oh nee nee schon wieder
ok es ist kein l dann ist es ein i dann ist es ein i auch nicht null
ein i ist es ein i und nur null oh wie kriege ich jetzt den link raus
monkaS warum ist das so kompliziert
m n a das ist ziemlich sicher eine null hinten dran oder
a lma 0 warum geht denn der kack wieder nett ich hasse diese seite das funktioniert immer
nicht ja das ist die seite die man mir im browser
steht nach nem upload falsch abgetippt direkt monkaS ja ok leute ich bin äh nicht in der
lage bin ich in der lage im igor zu verwenden gut dann zeige ich euch keinen 3d ausdruck
geht mir schon wieder auf den zack dass es nicht funktioniert
also falls sich irgendjener austoben will das müsste eigentlich die richtige adresse
sein post das mit dem handy in den chat a das ist
ne gute idee oh das ist huge brain alter hier hab ich natürlich den tap schon wieder zu
gemacht ich schlatz jetzt einfach nochmal auch
wir hams gleich ich hätt jetzt nicht gedacht dass du so
ein act ist einfach ein bild zu scheren was der link geht der link funktioniert überhaupt
nicht echt warum funktioniert der bei dir und hier funktioniert er nicht
äh warum warum geht der link und der geht nicht
der link ist exakt das gleiche hä huge was hab ich jetzt falsch gemacht zumindest
ähm ja so ein gehäuse kann man sich da zum beispiel ausdrucken das ist eigentlich das
was ich euch zeigen wollte ja hast du hier drinne ist ein microcontroller mit nem display
und letztendlich ist es ne es ist ne laura gateway das ist im prinzip für funk gedönst
ne das ist bestimmt ein l und kein i oder irgendwas ach es ist ein großes a es ist
ein großes i die schraube ist lose ne die schraube ist einfach
ich hab noch nicht ganz reingedreht das ich wieder aufmachen kann
ich wollte nicht komplett dicht machen bis es fertig ist und auf den dachboden kommt
ja aber so viel zum thema ich speicher mir das mal weil das wahrscheinlich öfters als
frage kommt äh sowas kann man zum beispiel mit dem 3d drucker machen kann man sich gehäuse
für seine gerätschaften ausdrucken
achja und hier sind wir beim thema gaming steckdose steckdose mit rgb beleuchtung
das ist richtig next level shit hier
ja und wie sind wir da jetzt drauf gekommen von von ner steckdosenleiste ne na gut zumindest
ähm mit der steckdosenleiste kann ich jetzt so machen dass wenn ich auf mein raspberry
gehe zum uploaden von einem 3d drucker job dann kann der automatisch auch über die api
von ner steckdosenleiste den port einschalten wo der 3d drucker dran ist und da muss der
3d drucker nicht an sein die ganze zeit und ich muss nicht rüber rennen und den 3d drucker
anmachen also für genau sowas ist es sinnvoll wenn man eine steckdosenleiste hat die man
flashen kann und eine steckdosenleiste hat die man äh über ein webinterface oder über
ner api ansprechen kann
kannst du die schrauben auch selber ausdrucken das geht allerdings ähm nicht so gut
also du kannst keine metallschrauben drucken logischerweise aber gewinde drucken und so
ist nicht so schön
kannst du über die steckdose auch den schrumpfverbrauch messen
also über über diese steckdosenleiste geht das nicht
aber die hier kann das
die hier kann das von der von der sorte habe ich ein paar bei mir im haus verteilt das ist
eine seawave steckdose die hat ähm
zeig euch mal welche das ist
nein
die da ist es
ähm die ist ziemlich gut die hat ja oben halt ganz normal den äh den stecker den man
den man äh remote schalten kann und unten hat sie unten hat sie nen knopf für ein
und aus das verfügen da drüber sowas simples wie den knopf haben auch viele billigere
spart dingspump steckdosen nicht und es hat noch 2 usb anschlüsse also für mich ist
es bisher die beste steckdose die ich für seawave gefunden hab und das schöne bei seawave
ist ja wenn man ein gerät angesteckt hat am stromnetz dann erweitern die das seawave netzwerk
und das wird stabiler das heißt ein paar steckdosen davon im haus verteilt und es
ist wunderbar stabil
was halten die dinge aus an strom da durch geht
musst du mal gucken naja gut was halten die dinge aus das ist das ist nen so nen so nen
dingspump standard stecker dann werden das was sein 230 volt 16 ampere nee 10 ampere
was ist es 16 10 sinds glaub ich ne was für was diese 16
das muss ja konform sein zu dem was da ach hier 230 sinds wahrscheinlich ach doch bis
16 aber 230 mal 16 sind keine 2300
das ist kein china relay ich glaub das ist schon ein bisschen was besseres hier
zumindest für die meisten sachen reicht das dicke wenn du daran jetzt irgendwie den
herd anschließen willst oder so dann würde ich das nicht unbedingt machen
ich denke mal waschmaschine trockener kann man da dran anschließen
kannst ja bestimmt noch nen heizlüfter oder sowas dran anschließen
ja aber das ding ist nicht nicht verkehrt
ja so jetzt sind wir von der usb steckdosenleiste zu 3d drucker gekommen zu rgb steckdosen
und zu alle möglichen machen wir mal weiter leider ist das hier anscheinend keine flash
barre sonst wird sich das lohnen heute zu kaufen
hab ich noch irgendwas übersehen
was wie sind geschwindigkeitsangaben bei switches zu verstehen wenn ein switch 1 gigabit pro
sekunde kann heißt das ich kann pro port gleichzeitig ein gigabit pro sekunde nutzen
oder kann ich nur dix haben das kommt drauf an also ein ordentliches ein ordentlicher switch
hat einen datenblatt dabei wo das drin steht was die backplane so kann wenn du nen gigabit
switch hast dann heißt das erstmal nur dass deine netzwerk ports sünken oder halt nen
link kriegen mit einem gigabit das heißt noch gar nichts drüber aus was du da theoretisch
drüber kriegst funktioniert seawave über ne cloud ne ne das ist alles lokal wenn du
zum beispiel mal hier guckst wenn man es hier mal zum beispiel bei meiner mikrotikrouter
gucken der hat auch nen switch eingebaut die schreiben hier nämlich im datenblatt irgendwo
muss man mal gucken wo das steht schreiben die was du drüber kriegst also je nach switch
heißt das gar nichts dass das ein gigabit switch ist der hier macht maximal bridging
ohne filter rules macht er so keine ahnung 2 gigabit so irgendwie in dem dreh wenn ich
das jetzt richtig interpretiere was da steht ja also du kannst bei nem billig switch auf
jeden fall nicht alle ports mit gigabit laufen lassen und also wohlgemerkt gigabit drüber
jagen was ungefähr 120 mb 125 mb entspricht und das auf allen ports das funktioniert
bei nem billig switch garantiert nicht der port sünkt der port kriegt nen gigabit link
das ist alles was das sagt was letztendlich drüber übertragen werden kann das hängt
von dem jeweiligen von der jeweiligen hardware ab die der switch anbieter verbaut du hast
jetzt gesehen bei nem relativ günstigen mikrotikrouter und die sind schon deutlich besser als das
was du wahrscheinlich sonst so kriegst von tp link und so sind es ungefähr 2 gigabit
und bei irgendwelche billig switchen kann ich mir auch vorstellen kannst die ganze ecke
weniger sein aber wohlgemerkt das bezieht sich ja nicht darauf dass du geräte anschließen
kannst die gigabit netzwerk haben sondern die auch gigabit übertragen und wenn du
2 ports hast oder wenn du insgesamt 2 gigabit hast finde das ist ok mehr brauchst du in
der regel daheim auch nicht was ein 8 port switch und davon machen ja nicht versuchen
ja nichtmal ansatzweise alle geräte viel traffic zu machen wenn du mehr brauchst musst du
den dementsprechend teureren switch kaufen deine bessere backplane hat der mehr bandbreite
also muss man kurz sagen nur weil gigabit drauf steht heißt es nicht dass der auch nur
gigabit überträgt oder weder mehr noch weniger das sagt gar nichts drüber aus außer dass
du gigabit netzwerkgeräte dran verwenden kannst hast du einen p-hole das hört sich
immer so übelst pervers an aber den p-hole hast du einen p-hole hatte ich wer das nicht
kennt das ist ein adblocker über dns also sprich das ist ein dns server der einfach domains
von denen bekannt ist dass darüber ads verteilt werden nicht auflöst habe ich nicht mehr
ich hatte es nur ganz kurz ich hatte es früher nicht weil die browser teilweise übelst lahm
dadurch geworden sind weil die unnütz gewartet haben auf irgendwelche namensauflösungen
danach hatte ich es mal ein halbes jahr oder ein jahr und jetzt habe ich es nicht mehr
weil twitch und youtube so clever geworden sind und die ads über den gleichen server
ausliefern wie auch den videocontent und deswegen funktionieren sollte dns werbeblocker
nicht mehr richtig weißt du ob man aus den portable ssd die ssd ausbauen kann da sind
ja auch bestimmt normale m2 drin das kommt ganz auf das ganz auf das gerät an vielleicht
haben sie auch direkt irgendwie dann usb interface dran gewurstet oder so keine ahnung da würde
ich immer mal gucken auf reddit oder generell einfach mal danach suchen ob es nicht zu diesem
gerät schon irgendwelche anleitungen gibt so wo sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben
hier das ist nicht das wo wir waren oder hier smartphone das hatten wir alles schon durchgeguckt
mehr oder weniger und haben festgestellt es ist ach guck mal was es da gibt das ist meine
steckdosenleiste das ist ein prime angebot das ist ein prime angebot was ein prime angebot
ist ach nee das das hat noch gar nicht angefangen oder beginnt um 12 vor 4 wie 12 vor 4 morgen
um 12 vor 4 also leute wir hatten es ja eben von der von der steckdosenleiste die man flaschen
kann ach nee das ist doch eine andere warum sind das da vier und da wieder ja also da
könnt ihr morgen mal reingucken das ist 100 pro die gleiche china steckdosenleiste die
ich auch hatte sieht sieht genauso aus wie die andere und ist bestimmt das gleiche gleiche
china zeug drinne wenn die morgen günstiger ist als 29 euro dann lohnt sich das zu kaufen
wenn man eine flashbare flashbare hersteller flashbare steckdosenleiste haben will das
ist vom aufbau her exakt das gleiche wie die die ich hab die ganze 100 pro aufflaschen
das ist so ein das ist ja nicht der richtige hersteller das ist alles die gleiche china
steckdosenleiste so also in welche kategorie wollen wir jetzt noch gucken wir haben ja
tatsächlich schon ein paar halbwegs brauchbare sachen heute gefunden wieder einfach gönnen
ihr mal nee ich hab gerade mit dem zweiten mal reingehört auf dem zweiten monitor äh
der zweiten rechner habe ich mir gedacht nee das äh kenne mich nicht so gut aus ist china
smartzeug nicht problematisch gegen angreife von außen ähm ja und nee also gegen angreife
von außen kommt drauf an ja kommt auf den kommt auf den hersteller an wie er das gemacht
hat aber prinzipiell würde ich mich überhaupt nicht auf china zeug verlassen ähm deswegen
kaufe ich mir auch nur china zeug was man selber flaschen kann zum beispiel habe ich
ja eben gerade gezeigt haben wir vor irgendwie 4 5 streams gemacht haben wir eine steckdosenleiste
genommen ähm haben wir diese steckdosenleiste genommen die ist vom china hersteller und
komplett nur über china cloud zu verwenden und die würde ich normalerweise bei mir daheim
auch nicht verwenden und die haben wir geflasht das heißt das ganze china zeugs jetzt weg
ja sebaro war ja klar dass irgendwie sowas kommt wir gucken jetzt wir gucken jetzt mal
nach ob es für den sebaro ein paar das ist doch was für den sebaro hier oder
das ist doch eher was endlich jetzt interessant
dann sind wir schon am start drei stunden die zeit geht so schnell rum
die stream so das ist der wahnsinn
heftig wie schnell das immer geht ich gucke jetzt mal noch durch ob es hier noch irgendwelche
streaks die steckdosen geflasht das war vor 17 streams ja das liegt aber auch nur daran
weil mir das so kurz vorkommt weil ich gefühlt jeden tag oder jeden zweiten tag geschrieben
habe so nicht so lange her
wenn wir gerade dabei sind steckdosenleiste flash stream bei sind ups gibt es hier und
zwar china steckdosenleiste flaschen da ist das stream dazu da flaschen wir die da flaschen
wir die steckdosenleiste irgendwo da oder wo immer da da flaschen wir die steckdosenleiste
gerade warum chromium und nicht firefox warum nicht chromium chrome firefox und vivaldi
und nicht zu vergessen den opera gaming browser
kannst du die wots eigentlich irgendwie safen dass die für immer auf twitch sind nicht
die liege werden ja kann ich wo blorz punkt tv da gibt es eine kategorie die sich archiv
nennt und im archiv sind alle streams drinne bitte auf ein paar ausnahmen hat das sebaro
gemacht eine runde mal hier pock nein eine runde mal pock für den sebaro alle streams
da gut so ja wollen wir uns noch eine kategorie angucken also wir haben jetzt smart home durch
das ist eigentlich die sache die mich interessiert hat wir haben uns bisschen die elektronik
geschichten angeguckt und hardware sind dann was sind dann die highlights überhaupt notbox
waschmaschinen kühlschränke in kühlschrank was gibt es für kühlschränke klingt jetzt
ein bisschen random aber ich könnte neue kühlschrank kichengeräte brauch ich nicht tablets haben
sich auch gelohnt also die amazon tablets auf jeden fall ich würde ja theoretisch sogar
einen stream machen werkzeuge ja das gucken wir noch sehr gute idee unter was stehen die
denn heim und garten oder wo stehen werkzeuge drunter kühlschrank flaschen also ich würde
ja einen stream machen wo wir einen amazon fire tablet flaschen allerdings weiß ich
nicht wie happy amazon darüber ist kannst du eine laptop hersteller empfehlen den letzten
laptop den ich mir geholt habe der ist das ist zehn jahre her also leider nicht den den
ich den ich unten habe das glaube ich von dell aber der war damals auch schon nicht
sonderlich toll das war so ein budget ding ne also die richtig gute zum arbeiten schreiben
sie schon im chat sind sind von lenovo sind aber auch nicht ganz günstig aber die sind
robust und sie haben mittlerweile wieder glaube ich metallscharniere
stand da eben bei highlights ach ok echt ach hier ach nee das sind das sind nur nur
die einen hersteller hatten wir jemanden kategorie mit werkzeug ansonsten gehen wir einfach auf
alle angebote und sagen dann baumarkt oder so genau
blau beste ja für das was haben es wirklich nicht übel ich habe von den plus einen akkuschrauber
und den sonst noch was nee das war so ein akkuschrauber
die das nix dabei war spräuchte zangen habe ich schon alle möglichen und sogar ein talkset
habe ich jetzt um mich mal wieder selbst dran zu erinnern aber ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
nicht was ich meine außer ein paar die beim streben dabei waren
baumarkt ok was geht das ist so ein rasen also das ist eine sache die ich mir wahrscheinlich
nicht holen werde ich habe mir gerade in den höchsten tönen über staubsaugerroboter
geschrieben gesprochen mein brain ist schon mittlerweile komplett kaputt nach drei stunden
wieder rasenmehroboter werde ich mir in nächster zeit nicht anschaffen es kann aber ihr kennt
mich das kann sein dass ich das jetzt erzähle und morgen sage ich habe mir einen gekauft
aber ich habe mir nicht vor einen zu kaufen weil das sich für unseren garten nicht sonderlich
gut eignet aber unser garten ist ziemlich uneben als wurzel nicht ganz klar wo bed anfängt
wo bed aufhört nur rasenmehroboter mehr roboter flaschen ja also wenn sollte ich mir einen
kaufen dann auf jeden fall einen der nur ohne cloud funktioniert oder flashbar ist ich könnte
noch eine astschere gebrauchen garten und elektroartikel bis zu 50 prozent reduziert
da gucken wir doch jetzt mal west of baumarkt 30 prozent reduziert da gucken wir mal brauchen
wir alles nett was hat das denn mit baumarkt zu tun wenn man dreckig ist muss man die haren
wäschen wenn man von zu viel aber dreckig ist am baumarkt muss man die haren wäschen
machen wir alles nett amazon basics gucken wir auch noch mal rein klopapierhalter na
endlich ruhig auf die erd stellen achtfach steckdosenleiste super solid wozu eine achtfach
steckdosenleiste kaufen wenn man auch eine vierfach china steckdosenleiste für den
doppelten preis haben kann mit web interface das sieht einfach aus wie einen sonoff bloß
mit anderem namen drauf naja also schau mal naja das ist was ok kärcher hochdruckreinigungs
kann zeug schnee brauche ich alles nett brauche ich alles nicht brauche ich alles
nicht mehr robot brauche ich alles nicht naja brauche ich nicht brauche ich nicht brauche
ich alles nicht gar nur elektro artikel 50 prozent reduziert kann man das auch schon
näher ein sack schlauch für vier meter zuck brauche ich auch alles nicht akkulaubleiser
ist auch sowas brauche ich auch alles nicht heckenschere brauche ich auch nicht das ist
jetzt eher gedacht mal so ordentliches werkzeug oder so ein paar schraubendriesor könnte ich
noch brauchen ich habe letztens ein paar verloren ich weiß nicht wo die hin sind gaming hochdruckreiniger
mit rgb ja bei amazon basics hatten wir schon guck mal leute eine monitor halterung für
80 euro wie sowas möglich ich dachte sowas kostet 1000 euro warum ist das warum ist das
möglich für 80 euro das verstehe ich nicht ich verstehe das nicht apple hat gesagt es
kostet 1000 euro und und und der wall mount kostet 200 euro bei apple warum wie kann das
sein dass es nur 80 euro kostet guck mal der wall mount kostet 17 euro ich habe apple vertraut
und jetzt sehe ich hier das stimmt nicht was apple gesagt hat jetzt und steigte im guck
an twitteren apple fanboys kommen nicht wir auch verleben klar apple fanboys waren diesmal
sogar selber ziemlich stinkig hat man gesehen also apple fans fanden es diesmal auch ziemlich
affig dass denn für den 5000 euro monitor kein monitor stand drinne ist ich mein wenn
man gesagt hätte das ist ein 5000 euro monitor und hier könnt ihr euch für 1000 euro noch
einen super geilen stand dabei kaufen ok aber das sind 5000 euro monitor keinen fuß hat
wo gibt es denn sowas ey was schau dir das hier mal an das ist wahrscheinlich apple
bash video gehe ich mal von aus 30 sekunden ok was zu leise genug genug leute ja das ist
der witz das ist das was ich meine warum warum gibt es in 5000 euro display ohne einen stand
guck guck mal das ist genau das was ich meine mount 200 euro amazon mount 17 euro pro stand
da
der mount auf amazon ist auch dreck das kann sein das kann sein das will ich gar nicht
bestreiten dass der mount auf amazon dreck ist oder oder weder noch b noch entstehen
zumindest ist der preisunterschied dazwischen ganz schön hart und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
dass du unter 200 euro kein ordentlichen kein ordentlichen weser mount kriegst und der eigentliche
witz ist ja gar nicht mal der weser mount gewesen sondern der monitor ständer für das
glaube ich nicht dass du dass du keine weserhalterung für unter 100 für unter 200 euro kriegst
oder selbst du kriegst bestimmt ein ordentliches weser mount für wahrscheinlich sogar für
deutlich unter 100 ich weiß was ist da großartig dran oder was kann man da großartig dran
verkacken das ding braucht braucht eine platte das braucht die löcher im richtigen abstand
und ein paar schrauben also ich wüsste nicht was man da großartig was da großartig dran
teuer sein muss aber man kann keinen für unter 100 mit einem ab 100 vergleichen warum
nicht was hat denn was hat denn eine halterung ab 100 euro ich meine im prinzip ist es eine
plastikplatte mit löchern für schrauben was kann die denn so geile features haben
dass man 100 euro mehr ausgibt wenn es keine ahnung 30 euro tun würden ich meine ok vielleicht
das material aber das macht es dann auch nicht so fett rgb halterung richtig stimmt da habe
ich gar nicht dran gedacht stimmt dass das würde ich mir natürlich noch gefallen lassen
wenn es der rgb haltung ist also mich würde das wirklich interessieren vielleicht macht
er aber nur macht viel aus ja klar das hast du ja bei gehäusen auch wenn du billige gehäuse
anguckst kannst auch sage ich verstehe schon so ungefähr was du meinst wenn du dir ganz
billiges gehäuse anguckst kann man auch sagen ey das ist ein gehäuse guckst du dir ein bisschen
besseres gehäuse an wirst du feststellen dass es ordentlich entgradet du schleidest
dich nicht an manchen stellen es ist von der aufteilung her besser klar ist da bestimmt
in ähnlichem maße auch so ja also es werden bestimmt qualitätsunterschiede sein zwischen
einem 15 euro mount und einem 100 euro mount da muss man halt gucken ob es das preis leistungsmäßig
einem wert ist oder das den brauche ich nicht an amazon basis ein usb hub könnte ich tatsächlich
noch ein brauchen ein ultra mini hub was ich das billig aus nicht nur billig das sieht
auch billig aus 30er pack wozu 30er pack also wenn ich mir 30er pack kaufen würde dann
würde ich mir den wirklich bei aliexpress bei den chinesen kaufen was da gab es ein
micro du ich glaube das ist gar nicht so schlecht wenn man also wenn man exakt sowas braucht
die qualität kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht mit dem ordentlichen vergleichen aber wahrscheinlich
wenn man wirklich genau sowas braucht gar nicht mal so kacke es sieht eher ein bisschen
aus wie wie ein übergroßes zäpfchen oder so ne aber wenn man genau sowas braucht ist
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht
es ist schon 20 uhr die zeit geht so schnell rum
Leute ich würde sagen wir machen schluss ich gucke mal ob es so irgendwann gibt den man
hosten können ich muss jetzt nämlich noch was futtern
und ich muss leider morgen wieder aufstehen um 5 uhr 45 wo ich ja wahnsinnig viel bock
drauf habe wir gucken noch mal schnell wenn wir hosten
können ist jemand online von den leuten den ich followe ja
ich gucke ich gucke weder loll noch pub cam aber wahrscheinlich habe ich mir irgendwann
mal gedacht ist eine gute idee warum nicht
es liegt sich selbst
bei
Sommercl- Oh Gott, der Titel, ey.
Okay, was macht er da?
Was macht er?
Was hat er denn da unten in seinem Rechner?
Ist das eine Wasserkühlung?
Ist das der Radiator von der Wasserkühlung?
Wir hausten jetzt den Hardware-Umbauer.
Den haben wir das letzte Mal gehostet, ne?
Der hat ewig gestreamt.
Der hat irgendwie 8 Stunden oder so Java programmiert.
Ich lerne Unity streamen.
Was ist das?
Cisco Packet Tracer.
IP-Berechnung.
Der will wissen, das ist bestimmt ein Azubi, der...
Der gucken will, wie es... oder?
Ne, mit 29 nicht.
Packet Tracer IP-Berechnung.
Das wäre doch was für euch hier.
Wir haben doch viele Azubis am Start.
Ich lerne Unity kennen.
Okay, der lernt wirklich als Unity kennen, wie es aussieht.
Komm, wir hausten den Hardware-Umbau-Typ.
Packet Tracer? Ich mag Packet Tracer.
Okay, Leute.
Es war schön, dass heute so viele dabei waren.
Wenn ihr nicht gefollowed seid, wäre schön, wenn ich euch das nächste Mal auch im Stream wieder begrüßen dürfte.
Also, follow button.
Und ansonsten gibt es mir auch auf YouTube, Twitter.
Und wir haben ein neues Ding, das ist auch ein Discord.
Ausrufezeichen Discord.
Und wir machen an der Stelle Schluss.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Schön, dass so viele dabei waren.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss.
Und ich hauste jetzt den Hardware-Umbau-Dude, der sein PC heiß macht.
Oder was auch immer.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.